Monka W.
Man könnte auch sagen Monka W in ordentlichen Sprachen.
Ich hab keinen Bock, Leute.
Und nicht aufs Streamen.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Ich hab keinen Bock.
Kick Wait.
Moin, ihr erstens schon am Start.
Ja, das wird morgen auch wieder schlimm auf der Arbeit.
Da wünschen sich alle Leute immer.
Ja, und wie war es bei Weihnachten?
Und wie hast du Neujahr verbracht?
Und wir wünschen dir einfach...
Da krieg ich immer Anfälle, ey.
Ich bin nicht so der Gratulierer.
Ja, der Titel, der ist vertippt.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich hab noch nicht mal Bock, den Titel anzupassen.
Ja, genau.
Du hast schon genau erfasst.
Du weißt, um was es geht.
Ich hab absolut keinen Bock, morgen auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Ich hatte jetzt ein bisschen über einen Monat frei.
Jetzt muss ich wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock.
Was kann ich an der Arbeit legen?
Ich hatte nur...
Ich hab nie Bock.
Das legt sich die ersten paar Stunden dann wieder.
Aber ich hab nie Bock nach, wenn man einen Monat lang den Kreiselgrind des Todes machen kann,
dann wieder arbeiten zu gehen.
Sicherlich.
Wird sich der ein oder andere jetzt denken.
Max, beschwer dich nicht.
Du kannst zum größten Teil Homeoffice machen und hast nur vier Tage wochen.
Ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Da habt ihr recht.
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Ist es auch nicht.
Aber es geht mir trotzdem auf den Sack.
Ich hab trotzdem keinen Bock.
Also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich egal, ja.
Keckweight.
Monka ist echt...
Ich mein, ich hab schon den ganzen Tag jetzt keinen Bock.
Aber jetzt, wo ich weiß, so demnächst muss ich dann mal pennen gehen.
Erst drei Stunden oder so muss ich mal pennen gehen.
Und morgen aufstehen und auf die Arbeit fahren.
Da hab ich überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hab mir das ja auch blöd vorgenommen.
Ich hab auch gesagt, ich fahr gleich den ersten Dienstag auf die Arbeit.
Wobei das gar nicht so schlimm ist.
Dann hab ich wenigstens die Woche gleich hinter mir.
Oh, nee.
Und das wird morgen schlimm.
Das wird morgen richtig schlimm auf der Arbeit.
Da sind sie sich alle wieder...
Weil das so der erste Tag ist, wo sie sich alle sehen.
Und Neujahr war und Weihnachten war und so.
Und so.
Da gratulieren sie sich dann alle immer einen halben Tag lang.
Und ihr wisst ja, wie ich auf solche Social-Sachen stehe.
Nee, Hände schütteln mach ich nicht.
Aber muss man sagen.
Und was hast du, äh, was hast ich Weihnachten gemacht?
Und wie geht's dir vor?
Ich sag da einfach gar nix.
Ich sag da einfach so, ja, alles überlebt, passt schon.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich hab halt keinen Bock auf solche Social-Sachen, wisst ihr doch.
Nö.
Ihr kennt mich doch.
Und die, mit denen ich zusammenarbeite, öfters mal, die kennen mich da in der Richtung auch schon.
Aber die anderen halt nicht.
Schreib ne Rund-Mail.
An was soll ich...
Soll ich an IT-Gesamt schreiben oder was?
Haha, nee.
Und außerdem, das, das...
Guck mal, selbst wenn ich ne Mail schreib, meinst du, das hält davon ab, dass die Leute das alle sagen?
Nö.
Außerdem, bin doch nicht blöd, schreib ne Mail, dann denken die Leute doch, ich will da drüber reden.
Jo.
Fast in Dubai im Penthouse.
Bei Apporet oder wo.
Haha.
Ähm.
Ja, glücklicherweise, glücklicherweise, hab ich den Eindruck, geht's nicht ganz so lang.
Das ist meistens...
Äh.
Das, das, das Gute ist, das Gute ist, wenn ich morgen nach Frankfurt fahr, dann bin ich so, keine Ahnung, halb neun oder so, bin ich da.
Ich übertreib's ja nicht mehr, ich steh ja nicht mal fünf vor 45 auf, wie früher, ne, muss ich ja nicht mehr übertreiben.
Äh, ich bin dann halb neun da.
Dann sind noch nicht so viele andere da.
Guck ich mir mal das neue Büro an.
Wir haben nämlich ein neues Büro gekriegt.
Während ich weg war, hab ich mitgekriegt.
Da hab ich sogar jetzt einen richtig, echten, eigenen Platz.
Die ganze Zeit im alten Büro hatte ich ja keinen, das war zu klein.
Was ja nicht schlimm war, ich hab immer auf so einer Wechselarbeitsplatzfläche gesessen.
Was mir persönlich sogar lieber ist, ich mag das, wenn da so täglich die Leute so ein- und ausgehen irgendwie.
Ich mag so Wechselarbeitsplätze, Flächen.
Was ich auch mag ist, dass die Leute ihre Plätze nicht dekorieren, sondern dort ist halt am Ende des Tages,
muss der Platz wieder aufgeräumt sein.
Und das mag ich, das gefällt mir.
Ich hab noch, ich hab noch nicht mal ne Schublade, ich hab im Schrank, hab ich ein Fach,
da leg ich immer meine Maus und Tastatur rein, mehr brauch ich nicht.
Der Rest ist im Rucksack.
Und was brauch ich schon?
Ich brauch mein Notebook, ich brauch mein Handy und ich brauch ein Ladekabel.
Okay, die Eintrittskarte brauch ich noch, ja.
Das war's, fertig.
Mehr, mehr muss es nicht sein.
Hm, ja.
Aber, es wird halb so wild, ich hab immer nur keinen Bock den Tag, bevor ich arbeiten muss, da drauf.
Aber sobald ich dann da bin und so, oder eigentlich schon, sobald ich aufgestanden bin, ist das gar nicht so wild.
Ja, also, es ist jetzt nicht super schlimm, ich kenn das ja schon, aber ich hab halt trotzdem keinen Bock.
Ich mein, man kann sich das vorstellen, man braucht bestimmt ne Woche, wobei, ganz ehrlich, eigentlich nicht.
Ich wollt grad sagen, man braucht ja immer ne Woche, wo man sich das vorstellen kann.
Ich wollt grad sagen, man braucht ja immer ein bisschen, bis man sich dran gewöhnt hat, jetzt frei zu haben, oder braucht man ein bisschen sich da dran zu gewöhnen, bis man, dass man wieder arbeiten muss, aber das Freihaben geht bei mir sehr schnell, die Gewöhnung, und umgedreht geht's aber auch sehr schnell.
Einfach, einfach mal ins Büro gesetzt und schon ist es wieder gut.
Nee.
Weder das eine noch das andere, ich trink keinerlei Energydrinks, ich trink auch keine, keine Cola, Fanta oder Kaffee.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige IT-Dude, der kein, kein Kaffee trinkt.
Hoodie hab ich auch seltener noch.
Guck, aber...
Vielleicht zieh ich tatsächlich morgen eins an.
Was kann man eigentlich anziehen, Leute?
Außer Hoodie und Hemd.
Gibt's da noch sowas dazwischen?
So ein Pulli vielleicht?
Ohne, also quasi in ein Hoodie ohne Hood.
Wenn die Bahn kommt, oh ja, oh je, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Jetzt sagst du was.
Jetzt, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Bahn?
Jetzt sagst du was, ich muss mal gucken.
Dass da morgen irgendwas ist.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mit, mit Streik und so aus?
Bahnstreik droht im Januar.
24rhein.de, okay.
Derwesten.de.
Gibt's da nicht, gibt's da nicht irgendwas?
Okay, derwesten.de meinetwegen.
Die Seite, die Seite sieht ja schon grausam aus, ja.
Außerdem übelst, übelste Flashbang.
Ja, deutsche Bahn.
Kunden müssen schlucken.
Jetzt rutscht sie.
Ach, Alter, was für ne Überschrift, was für ne Überschrift, Alter.
Der Weihnachtsfrieden läuft ab.
Ja, wisst ihr was, ganz ehrlich, wenn die, wenn die wie verrückt streiken, dann mach ich halt einfach mehr Homeoffice.
Was willst du machen?
Ich hab ja, also wenn ich keine Chance hab hinzukommen, hab ich keine Chance.
Klassisches Büro ausführt, Big, Big Herren hochgeschnittener in, was für ein Ding?
Ah ja, das, hm.
Das ist exzellent dafür.
Ah.
Ich wollte aber gerade gucken, was die Bahn morgen macht.
Lasst mich mal kurz schauen.
Hanau.
Was die Bahn halt mir für'n Scheiß vorschlägt.
Von Hanau zum nächsten Tegut.
Warum, warum schlägt das die Bahn-App vor?
Gibt da überhaupt keinen Sinn?
Aha, ich seh schon, erster Zug ist cancelled.
Erster Zug ist cancelled.
Allerdings jetzt.
Allerdings jetzt und nicht morgen früh.
Lass mich mal kurz, ähm.
Pilter, nee, Uhrzeit.
Die neue Bahn-App ist auch keine wirkliche Ausgeburt der Usability.
So, machen wir mal 7.30 Uhr einfach.
Da weiß ich, dass in dem Dreh immer was fährt.
Hm?
Ähm.
Nee, scheint, scheint bis jetzt zumindest nichts auszufallen.
Okay.
Ja.
Die haben garantiert viele tolle Überraschungen vorbereitet, von denen sie selbst jetzt noch nichts wissen.
Das ist ja das Beste.
Die sind immer, die Bahn ist immer selbst überrascht von ihren Sachen.
Und auf der anderen Seite bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass die sich zu vielen Sachen, wo sie von überrascht sind, was ausdenken, so als wüssten sie, was Sache ist.
So, von Notarzteinsatz am Gleis, Böschungsbrand, Verspätung eines vorausfahrenden Zuges, Personalmangel.
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich, diese ganzen Gründe, die dort immer gesagt werden.
Die stimmen halt zum größten Teil gar nicht.
Es wird einfach randomized irgendwas gesagt.
Weil es ist doch auch, zumal es jetzt mal seriously ist, es ist auch scheißegal, oder?
Es ist vollkommen egal, was die sagen.
Mir ist es, mich fuckt's ab.
Egal, ob das ein Böschungsbrand ist, ein Notfalleinsatz oder ein vorausfahrender Zug, der zu langsam ist.
Es ist mir scheißegal, es ist zu spät, der Rest ist mir egal.
Warum?
Die haben den Ausreden-Champ bei sich programmiert, intern.
Das glaube ich auch.
Aber wisst ihr, das ist mir doch sowas von.
Sowas von wurscht.
Weshalb das zu spät ist.
Die sollen das lieber machen wie in Tokio, wo der Typ, wenn es zwei Minuten Verspätung hat, sich öffentlich entschuldigt.
Wenn es nochmal Verspätung hat, er zurücktritt.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert in Japan, wenn die Bahn dreifach Verspätung hat unter dem gleichen Chef.
Ob der dann irgendwie, weiß ich, vom Hochhaus springen muss oder so.
Keine Ahnung, die sind da einfach relativ hart drauf.
Aber da sind ja schon Leute zurückgetragen.
Wegen ein paar, wegen ein paar Minuten.
So pünktlich, wer hier auch da ist.
Also, die Bahn ist da auch garantiert wieder.
Ich habe mich überrascht von ihrem Scheiß, man.
Naja.
Die haben da in Japan halt noch ein ganz anderes Pflichtbewusstsein, was das angeht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Trittfirmen sind sicherlich nicht das Hauptproblem, warum es bei der Bahn nicht funktioniert.
Das ist echt.
Hattet ihr damals in der Schule auch immer so blöde Diskussionen?
So nach dem Motto, Bus ist nicht gekommen oder sowas.
Und da kam die Lehre immer an, so nach dem Motto, ja, aber ohne, dass das irgendwie schriftlich bestätigt ist und so.
Ey, das ging mir immer so auf den Sack.
Also, ich bin zum größten Teil auch zur Schule gelaufen oder damals tatsächlich schon vereinzelt mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Weil ich nie viel mit dem Fahrrad gefahren bin früher.
Ich bin tatsächlich meistens zur Schule gelaufen, manchmal aber mit dem Bus.
Und immer, wenn irgendwas, also je nachdem, von wo, ja, von daheim oder vom Opa.
Und je nachdem, es war halt immer jetzt.
Irgendwann habe ich mir angedacht, ich meine, ich war so selten zu spät, ja.
Und wenn dann was war, habe ich mir gedacht, naja, dann trag mich halt als fehlend ein, who cares.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Also bei uns, bei uns in der Schule hatten sie so ein Käfig für die Fahrräder.
Der wurde nur zweimal am Tag dann aufgeschlossen unter Aufsicht.
Oder nee, nur in der Pause aufgeschlossen nach Aufsicht, irgendwie sowas.
Und nach, nach Stundenende.
Und dann stand dann immer einer und hat geguckt, dass die Fahrräder nicht kaputt gemacht werden.
Wenn du überlegst, das war bei mir schon so.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie das heute ist.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie es an irgendeiner Problemschule in Berlin zur heutigen Zeit ist.
Da traut sich wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr mit dem Fahrrad hin.
Weil die sicher sind, das Fahrrad ist danach weg oder kaputt.
Egal wie alt und schrottig das Fahrrad ist, es ist danach noch schrottiger.
Welche Länder in der Statistik, oh man, Moment was, wir haben, oh es gibt eine Statistik.
Zur Pünktlichkeit im Bahn, Bahnverkehr, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass die Geld verdienen müssen, aber bezahlen will ich dafür jetzt trotzdem nix.
Ist ja fast schon wie bei den Kokonas.
Wo teilweise Metalldetektoren, oder ist es da teilweise auch schon so schlimm,
dass die, dass die in Berlin an den Schulen Metalldetektoren brauchen,
was die, dass die Leute keine Messer und Sachen mitbringen?
Das, ich mein, das ist doch wirklich schon...
echt dann komplett vorbei alles, äh.
Da würde ich auch nicht freiwillig als Lehrer arbeiten mehr.
Bei dir zeigt sie nichts mit Bezahlen an.
Vielleicht bist du, vielleicht bist du eingeloggt oder so schon.
Vielleicht bist du eingeloggt?
Vielleicht, vielleicht muss man, vielleicht muss man sich inkognitonen.
Äh, ne.
Vielleicht muss ich Linux verwenden, die wissen, dass das besser ist.
Äh.
Okay, keine Chance.
Ich muss mich einloggen.
Nope, no pass.
Geht nicht.
Na, egal.
Ähm, letztendlich ist es mir auch egal, wie es in anderen Ländern aussieht, was die Bahnpünktlichkeit angeht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass viele noch schlechter sind und viele noch besser sind.
Was mich interessiert, ist das, wofür es für mich relevant ist.
Und das ist halt hier, ne, mit, und da ist laufend irgendwas.
So, Reboot.
Oh, guck mal, der Pea, habt ihr das gesehen?
Der Pepo ist schon fast am Schlafen.
Ja.
Tü-tü-tü-tü-tü-tü.
Ey, aber ich sag euch, das ist wirklich kacke, ne.
Wenn ihr einen Monat morgens aufstehen konntet, mal ein bisschen Sport gemacht habt und dann den ganzen Tag Kreisel kreint.
Und jetzt müsst ihr morgens aufstehen, einmal die Woche zumindest nach Frankfurt fahren und allgemein arbeiten.
Dann fuckt das schon irgendwie ab, ja.
Bist du gestern auch um 10 im Bett gewesen?
Nee.
Quatsch, wie kommst du da?
Hä?
Ach so, ja, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Du meinst, weil ich sonst auch immer ins Bett gehe?
Naja, also erstens bin ich die letzten Tage auch nicht immer um 10 ins Bett gegangen.
Also ich bin zwar immer, ich orientiere mich da drum.
In Wirklichkeit gehe ich ja meist eher so 23 Uhr oder so ins Bett.
Gerade Dezember, wenn ich frei habe.
23 Stunden.
Gestern, gestern bin ich, keine Ahnung, 0 Uhr, 0 Uhr 30 oder so ins Bett.
Was ist Simmax?
Ich traue mich, das nicht aufzumachen.
Auch wenn es eigentlich nichts Schlimmes sein kann.
Weil das mal ein Streaming ist.
Aha, da steht nichts drin.
Auch geil.
Ah ja, die Österreicher sind pünktlich.
Pünktlich, ja.
Man muss aber sagen, vielleicht faken die einfach nur ihre Bahnstatistik besser.
Weil bei uns sind die offiziellen Bahnstatistiken ja auch massiv, massiv geschönt.
Nix F.
Läuft alles wunderbar hier, der Stream.
Guck, keine Package Lost und sonst was.
Die rechnen sich das ja schön.
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, die Bahn, die schafft es tatsächlich.
Die Bahn macht ihre eigenen Statistiken mehr oder weniger.
Und faket schon zu Recht, was Sache ist.
Und sind trotzdem immer richtig krass unter den sich selbst.
Und die selbst gesteckten Ziele sind schon zu niedrig.
Ja, also die sind wirklich, das ist echt lächerlicher Verein.
Deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich so gut um die jetzt mittlerweile drum herum komme.
Einmal die Woche muss ich hin.
Und das halt, das ertrage ich gerade so.
Wenn es auch echt abfuck ist.
Jedes Mal, wenn was ist.
Und ich meine, ich sehe es ja auf Twitter, ja.
Ich kann mich da mittlerweile auch nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Es war einfach schon zu oft zu viel Bullshit bei der Bahn.
Ich kann mich da mittlerweile nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Also wenn ich rein rechtlich gesehen könnte,
so dass es nicht...
...echt schon fast illegal ist, was man schreibt.
Dann würde ich die sogar noch heftiger flamen.
Wenn ich könnte.
Wenn ich...
Wenn ich öffentlich, wenn ich dürfte.
Würde ich die noch härter flamen.
Also es gibt glaube ich nichts, was ich so sehr hasse auf der Welt, wie die Bahn.
Wo...
Ja, mache ich.
Wobei, noch stimmt ja nicht.
Es ist ja wieder.
Seit 2013 wieder.
Oder meinst du dazu...
Also seit 2013, ja.
Ja, also immer noch.
2013 ist ja schon einfach schon elf Jahre, gell.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Ich bin jetzt 14 Jahre auf YouTube.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Gut, ich meine, so viele Videos...
Ich habe die letzten...
Ich habe die ersten drei Jahre so viele Videos hochgeladen, wie die letzten zehn Jahre zusammen vielleicht.
Aber trotzdem, schon ganz schön lang.
Eigentlich habe ich ja geplant, im Dezember mehr zu streamen, wobei das ging eigentlich, aber...
Vor allem mehr Videos zu machen.
Da kam mir leider der MMO Kreiselgrind dazwischen.
Der war zu strong.
Ich habe gesehen, der Fabian ist auch am MMO Kreiselgrinden.
Ich war vorher beim Frasier im Stream.
Und der grindet irgendwelche komischen Weep Games.
Und er spielt tatsächlich, jetzt haltet euch fest.
MW2, äh sorry, nein MW...
MW3 2022 Multiplayer.
Leider können wir nicht zusammen spielen, aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstens, weil ich das Spiel nicht habe.
Ich würde es mir vielleicht kaufen, weil wir öfters zusammen spielen können.
Aber der ist halt immer schon spät da, wenn ich eigentlich schon nicht mal da bin.
Also es passt eigentlich, passt halt nicht.
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe die meisten, also auch das letzte, dieser...
Wie heißt denn das dort?
Developer Showcase Dinger.
Gesehen.
Ja.
Mein Problem ist, das Spiel ist halt auch schon so lange angekündigt und so lange in Entwicklung,
dass ich immer noch leicht skeptisch bin, ob es, auch wenn es ja anscheinend immer mal regelmäßig Progress macht,
ob das wirklich jemals rauskommt.
Ich meine, hey, es kommt wahrscheinlich ja raus als Camelot Unchained.
Camelot Unchained kommt nie raus.
Also da haben sie sich verkalkuliert.
Haben wir, haben wir zufälligerweise, Chat, haben wir irgendwelche...
Ich weiß, das ist ziemlich Nische, aber vielleicht haben wir ein paar...
Und ich habe ja auch ein paar mal Dark gestreamt und alte Dark-Leute haben sich ja gefreut auf Camelot Unchained.
Haben wir irgendwelche Camelot Unchained Backer hier gerade dabei?
Also ich habe das damals gebackt.
Also das hier, ich kann es einfach mal zeigen.
Das hier.
Nein, nein, nein.
Kickstarter.
Ja, also das hier, das habe ich ja mal gebackt vor zehn Jahren oder so.
Keine Ahnung, fragt mich nicht.
Und ich habe das Internal Beta Testing Tier gewählt, weil ich mir gedacht habe, oh cool.
Dark Nachfolger und jetzt intern testen mit, so mega geil.
Habe ich, habe ich gebackt.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal aufpassen, dass ich nicht über mein Headset fahre.
Sekunde, was ist hier?
Okay, viel besser.
So.
Und das war ja ursprünglich geplant.
Ich glaube, Release war Scheduled für 2016 oder so.
2016 oder so sollte, glaube ich, Release sein.
Und jetzt haben wir 2024.
Das ist schon über zehn Jahre.
Und die haben mittlerweile auch aufgehört, hier irgendwas zu posten.
Ich glaube, hier gibt es auch nichts mehr, oder?
Außer, dass die Leute ein bisschen pisst sind.
Guck mal, es lädt schon gar nicht mehr.
Ja, 2000, 2015 haben sie das letzte Update gepostet, Cake Wait.
Naja, also, da kommt Ashes of Creation auf jeden Fall eher raus als Camelot Unchained.
Ich muss aber den mal zumindest zugutehalten.
Also, das Geld ist weg.
Das werde ich nie wieder sehen.
Ist im Prinzip auch immer mit dem Risiko verbunden.
Schade um das Game.
Das Ding ist, im Vergleich zu anderen Kickstarter-Scams gehe ich davon aus, dass die nicht von Anfang an Leute scammen wollten.
Sie haben es einfach organisatorisch in den Sand gesetzt.
Geben es aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht zu.
Und wisst ihr was? Achso, ja, Refunds machen sie auch nicht.
So, und ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Fanboys, gerade auf Reddit.
Auf Reddit, es gibt ein Subreddit für das Game.
Da postet einmal im Monat einer was.
Aber es gibt total viele Fanboys, die da immer noch des Übels verteidigen.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Jetzt sagt mir mal, Leute.
Ein Spiel, was über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist.
Was würdet ihr dort, was würdet ihr dort in Newslettern erwarten?
Okay, nichts.
Steht noch nicht mal was drinne.
So, Newsletter.
Man sieht nach 10 Jahren Entwicklung.
Nach 10 Jahren Entwicklung sieht man Concept Arts.
Die können nichts zeigen von diesem Game, Alter.
Concept Arts.
Nach über 10 Jahren Entwicklung.
Fucking Concept.
Oh, oh.
Wir haben ingame, was aussieht wie 2005-Grafik.
Nice.
Es ist halt echt lächerlich, einfach nur noch.
Ihr könnt euch fast vorstellen, dass diese Post-KI generiert sind.
Ach.
Das tut es mir echt um das Game, beziehungsweise drum leid, was es hätte werden können.
Da kommt nie was raus.
Der Zug ist abgefahren, ey.
Muss ich abschreiben.
Was aber auch nicht so wild ist.
Ich mein ganz im Ernst.
Ich spiel Dark aktuell auf dem Freeshot.
Das ist die beste Version, die es je gegeben hat.
Also besser als live und besser als es damals gewesen ist.
Insofern.
Ich kann auch ohne Probleme noch 20 Jahre ein jetzt schon 20 Jahre altes Game spielen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann ist das Game halt...
Dann 40 Jahre alt.
Wen juckt's?
Es sieht jetzt schon alt aus.
In 20 Jahren sieht es halt noch älter aus.
Aber es interessiert mich ja nicht großartig.
Und es gibt ein paar Verrückte, die versuchen die Dark Assets in Unreal zu importieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob da was rauskommt.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, weil...
Neben Assets importieren und Game-Logik.
Hier sind ja noch nur zwei...
Komplett ein paar unterschiedliche Schuhe.
Naja.
Leider...
Leider ins Klo gegriffen hier.
Mit dem ganzen Kickstarter-Stelz hier.
Aber...
Ich hätt's mir halt nice vorgestellt.
Aber ist halt nicht.
Sascha, danke für den Sub.
Und ansonsten...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen.
Ich hab in letzter Zeit nichts mehr auf Kickstarter gemacht.
Ich hab ein paar Sachen gebackt.
Von der...
...sich selbst reinigen Hose.
Die Hose hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Und Camelot Unchained hab ich auch erzählt.
Zwei Sachen, wo ich mehrere hundert Euro in Sand gesetzt hab.
Und die anderen Sachen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Das war nichts großartiges.
Fällt gar nichts mehr ein, außer den zwei Sachen.
Ja, man merkt sich immer nur die Sachen, die schlecht sind.
Ja.
Aber ich hab die letzten Jahre nichts mehr auf Kickstarter gemacht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Es ist einfach...
Ich warte, bis die Sachen rauskommen.
Ja.
Ja, das ist das Ding.
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Mir fällt außerdem zwei Sachen, die es richtig kacke gelaufen ist.
Fällt mir gerade gar nichts ein.
Da müsst ihr mich hier nebenbei vom Kickstarter Account einloggen.
Ja.
Und...
Ich...
Ich hab die letzten Jahre über Abstand vom Kickstarter gehalten.
Genauso wie von Early Access Spielen.
Mich stört es auf Steam immer noch, dass man auf Steam nicht komplett und gut filtern kann, dass keine Early Access Sachen angezeigt werden.
Du kannst zwar manche Sachen so ein bisschen filtern, aber so dieses...
Also dieses...
Zeigt mir in nichts von Steam Early Access an, gibt es nicht.
Also du hast immer noch die Liste für dich oder sowas.
Ja.
Klickst du durch, denkst du, ey, sieht ja ganz interessant aus.
Machst du auf.
Aha.
Early Access.
Du weißt, dass ich da richtig drauf stehe.
Auf sich 3000 paar frohes Neues und frohe Weihnachten und alles Gute zum Geburtstag und hast nicht gesehen zu wünschen, gell?
Wenn du Early Access auf Steam filtern würdest, dann ist wahrscheinlich wirklich 90% raus mittlerweile.
Was meint ihr?
Statistisch gesehen.
Was meint ihr, wenn man es mal rein prozentual sich anguckt?
Wie viele Early Access Games, die quasi als Early Access Game auf Steam an den Start gehen, werden jemals fertig?
Und mit fertig meine ich nicht wirklich zu Ende entwickelt, sondern, dass sie oft nicht fertig sind.
Sondern, dass sie offiziell aus dem Early Access raus sind.
Wie viel Prozent?
30?
Oder weniger?
Oder mehr?
Was sagt ihr?
Was, was meine ich?
Also, minus 5, ja.
Fühlt sich zumindest so an.
Aber Factorio war, glaube ich, auch mal Early Access und ist aus dem Early Access raus.
Und es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr.
Also, es gibt ja durchaus die ein oder anderen.
Oder, äh, dieses, das, das eine Dungeon Keeper Remake kann man nicht sagen.
Das, äh, Neuauflage, die nicht Dungeon Keeper heißt, ist auch aus dem Early Access raus.
Also, wahrscheinlich, okay, ihr meint 30 Prozent ist noch zu viel.
Ja, eher 15, okay.
Ja, ja, vielleicht 15.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall wenig.
Popke war auch mal Early Access, richtig, ja.
Wobei ich da sagen muss, bei manchen Spielen ist es ja irgendwie mittlerweile auch so, gehört schon.
Es ist ja irgendwie mittlerweile auch so, gehört schon fast zum Running Gag.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, Dota 2 ist, glaube ich, immer...
Was, die Beta ist over?
Ich dachte, ich dachte, Dota ist offiziell immer noch Beta.
Ist es nicht?
Ich dachte, da steht immer noch Beta dran.
Ich meine, es gehört ja mal eine Zeit lang zum guten Ton, dass an irgendwelchen Spielen noch Beta immer dran ist.
Das haben sie auch ewig dran stehen lassen.
Ja.
Ja, Popke.
Popke, das muss ich echt sagen, auch wenn es echt nicht mal ein Game war, habe ich den Eindruck, dass das ganz gut läuft.
Vor allem in Asien und in Korea muss Popke richtig gut sein.
Also, von den Spielerzahlen her.
Also, Popke war ja mal eine Zeit lang, glaube ich, sogar vor Fortnite und Apex und dem ganzen Zeug.
Also, Popke ist gerade in Korea und so mega beliebt gewesen zwischenzeitlich.
Ich habe einmal den Fehler gemacht und habe mir ein Popke-E-Sport-Tournament angeguckt.
Oder zumindest nicht ein Tournament.
Ein Spiel.
Popke-E-Sport.
Leute, das war, seriously, das war, glaube ich, vier gegen vierer oder was?
Vierer-Squad ist es, gell?
Relativ sicher war das ein Vierer-Squad.
Und das war so unglaublich langweilig.
Die sind den ganzen Tag nur irgendwie rumgestelzt und am Ende haben sie ein paar Kills gemacht.
Also, da gucke ich mir tatsächlich lieber Warzone an von irgendwelchen Streamern, die versuchen 60 plus Killgames zu machen.
Das war so abfuck langweilig.
Popke-E-Sport.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste daran war?
Gar nicht so sehr, dass sie so gespielt haben.
Ich meine, die spielen halt so optimiert, was die Regeln hergeben.
Wenn die Regeln hergeben, es zählt, wer die Runde gewinnt.
Winner-Winner-Chicken-Dinner.
Und nicht, wer die meisten Kills macht.
Kein Wunder, dass die alle rumchillen.
Was viel schlimmer war, waren die Caster.
Die Caster mussten die ganze Zeit versuchen, das irgendwie zu hypen, was dort passiert.
So, it's getting intense, it's getting intense.
Und ich denke mir so, Alter, die liegen im Gras und haben einen anderen Spieler gesehen.
Das ist jetzt schon intense, oder was?
Also, die lagen halt im Gras alle und haben sich da rumgerobbt und haben mal initial gelootet und lagen halt die ganze Zeit nur rum.
Und dann hat mal ein Spieler einen anderen Spieler gespottet.
Nicht geschossen, einfach nur gesehen, ja.
Und dann sind die Caster ausgeflippt.
Oh, it's getting intense, it's getting hot.
Scheiße.
Mann.
Der Typ liegt halt einfach nur rum.
Und dann ging es weitere fünf Minuten, wo nur rumgelegen wurde.
Also, es war wirklich das langweiligste E-Sport-Game, was ich je gesehen habe überhaupt.
Puppke.
Weiß nicht, ob sich die Regeln da mittlerweile geändert haben, dass es nicht mehr so, so nennen wir es mal nett umschrieben, slow-paced ist.
E4ESL.
Ja, stimmt.
Das wurde ja mal kurz gespielt.
Was ist eigentlich, jetzt wo du gerade sagst, Battlefield 4 ESL E-Sport.
Was ist, ist jemals was aus Battlefield, wie hieß das denn?
Recursion oder so.
Incursion?
Recursion?
Irgendwie so.
Was ist denn da draus geworden?
Die hatten doch mal versucht, so einen, so einen E-Sport-Battlefield-Multiplayer-Part rauszubringen.
Das ist, das ist komplett im Sande verlaufen, oder?
Hat keine Sau interessiert.
Hat keiner gespielt.
Und wurde dann quasi auch, ja.
Ja, einfach nicht weiterentwickelt.
Ist das nicht Recursion oder so?
Incursion?
Battlefield 1 Incursion.
Ja, genau.
Competitive Match.
Ja, das hat sich nirgendswohin entwickelt.
Gibt es eigentlich, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, da habe ich mich schon lange nicht mal mit beschäftigt.
Gibt es eigentlich einen Plan für Battlefield 2022?
Dieses Jahr?
Dunkles Protokoll.
Kann man das eigentlich auf Englisch stellen?
Chat, gibt's, wo ist der offizielle Knopf?
Hier, führen wir das auf, da.
Man kann es hier oben zwar auch ändern, aber es muss ja da irgendwo ein Button für geben.
Kann es sein, dass Battlefield immer noch weniger Maps hat als Battlefield 4 zu Launch?
Es könnte sein, dass wir jetzt ungefähr die Launch-Anzahl erreicht haben.
Definitiv nicht, wie bei Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3 nach einem Jahr.
Ja.
Wo die ganzen DLCs da durch waren.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Also eins muss man ja sagen, die machen immer auch sehr viel Text um wenig.
Mal gespannt, wie es 2024 aussieht, ob wir demnächst Battlefield kriegen oder nicht.
Weil die Chancen, ja, man weiß ja nicht.
Sind ja, sagen wir mal so, sind wahrscheinlich schon gering auf neues Battlefield und sind wahrscheinlich noch deutlich geringer auf ein gutes Battlefield.
Nee, Hardline hat keiner vergessen, spielt bloß keiner mehr.
Die meisten Leute, die da waren, als das rausgekommen ist, können sich durchaus noch an Hardline erinnern.
Hardline war auch mal ganz nice für ein paar Runden, hat aber extrem schnell die, ich will jetzt noch nicht mal sagen Faszination, die Anziehung verloren.
Ja.
Und dann war es ziemlich, ziemlich schnell dead.
Ich meine, wir können ja mal just for fun gucken.
Ähm, Server.
Ja.
Hey, hey, hey, immerhin.
Leute, einen Server gibt es noch.
Hotwire.
Downtown.
Ich meine, wir haben immerhin einen.
Hier ist ja nicht mal was gesetzt großartig.
Äh.
Ich meine, es gibt immerhin einen Server.
Einen Server und, na gut, man sieht es hier relativ genau, 65 aktive Spieler.
Wie sieht denn das, wie sieht denn das bei Battlefield, wie sieht es eigentlich bei Venice Unleashed aus?
Hat da mal wieder einer reingeguckt in letzter Zeit?
Keck, keck, wait.
Haben die ihre, ihre Crashes wieder gefixt?
Na, immerhin, immerhin, guckt mal da.
Guckt mal da.
Bei Battlefield 3 sind es immerhin, immerhin kannst du TDM, Nosha, Candles Only, vielen, nein, was sonst?
Was sonst?
Ja.
Das Problem mit dem Reality-Mod ist, dass es auch niemand spielt.
Ich hab, ich hab das am Anfang, am Anfang mir angeguckt.
Hab mir gedacht, okay, das dauert schon ein bisschen, bis man da reinkommt.
Aber im Endeffekt, ich hatt's dann nach, nach, keine Ahnung, 3, 4 Monaten oder so nach Release nochmal aufgemacht.
Da war im Prinzip keiner mehr eingeloggt.
Also, Nosha, Candle.
Äh.
Bitz.
Q.
Zep.
Beb.
Was auch immer.
Ähm.
Die Commodots werden es wissen.
All Maps.
Recruiting.
Der TBG-Clan, den gibt's auch gefühlt überall, oder?
Der, die, die haben auch, die haben auch Back Company 2 Server und sowas.
So, also, ich mein, immerhin.
Wir können, kann man noch, kann man Rush gescheit spielen irgendwo noch?
So als bester, bester Spielmodus ever?
Ob die noch Leute haben, die, die Battlelog überhaupt maintainen können?
Sieht nämlich nicht mehr so aus, oder?
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich broken.
Doch.
Banana Republic.
Ja, den, den kenn ich.
Da hab ich auch ein paar Mal drauf gespielt.
Es gibt im Prinzip die zwei Server.
Damavent Peak, Only, Rush, 64 Slot oder Banana Republic.
So die zwei.
Computerfest.
Immerhin, immerhin noch mehr.
Und wo es tatsächlich gar nicht so wenige Server gibt, kann man ja einfach 4 draus machen.
Wo es tatsächlich gar nicht so wenige Server gibt, kann man ja einfach 4 draus machen.
Wo es tatsächlich gar nicht so wenige Server gibt, ist Battlefield 4.
Man, man glaubt es kaum, aber sogar Battlefield 4 wird noch ganz gut gespielt.
Ist blöd, wenn du gebannt bist von einem der beiden aktiven Server, ne?
Battlefield 3 ist mittlerweile so alt, das ist zwar offen wie ein Scheunentor für Cheats und alles,
aber ich glaube, es wird sehr relativ selten gecheatet, oder?
Weil das Spiel ist so alt und uninteressant geworden, die Leute das jetzt noch spielen, spielen es halt um des Spieles Willens
und nicht um zu cheaten.
um zu cheaten außerdem hast du wahrscheinlich auf
diese ich meine das ist ein einziger server da sind vielleicht öfters auch
apartments am start wirst wirst aber halt wahrscheinlich auch relativ schnell
gebannt wenn du einfach nur mal glückliche runde hast ich würde mir
echt wünschen dass sie noch mal ein battlefield hinkriegen mit dem gleichen
hype wie battlefield 3 dass ich meine battlefield 4 ging schon runter der
ganze der ganze hype drum aber so einen hype wie um battlefield 3 oder nicht
nur ein hype um battlefield 3 sondern weil hype hatten die spieler am anfang
initial immer mal ganz kurz sondern auch einen beständigen hype so wie das
battlefield 3 hat das war einfach so mega nice dass du zwei jahre lang das
spiel durchgrinden konnte jeder hatte bock drauf
schade dass sie es nicht noch noch ja eigentlich eigentlich ja auch nur
richtig in den jahr bis das bis der content durch war eigentlich hätten sie
battlefield 4 noch ein jahr später bringen
sollen und das battlefield 3 noch versorgen aber das ist jetzt alles
ungelegte eier und zehn jahre her who cares ja hast du mal finals gespielt
nein gespielt habe ich nicht ich habe es mir angeguckt ich habe sie aber lost
glaube ich angeguckt und ich habe es mir bei einem koreanischen streamer angeguckt
und ich habe ein bisschen angeguckt ich muss sagen rein vom angucken habe ich
nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt ob das was es jetzt genau ist es hat auf der
einen seite ein bisschen zerstörung
wie man das so von da ist titeln kennt es hat aber rum gespringen mit auf
dächern und es hat irgendwie extraction oder sowas ich habe es nicht kapiert
ehrlich gesagt den den spielmodus das war so eine mischung aus extraction und
tdm the finals mit wiederbeleben ganz merkwürdig ja ich habe es ich habe es
vom angucken nicht gecheckt aber wahrscheinlich muss man das spiel noch
zu checken ich habe ich habe es nicht kapiert ich habe aber nicht wirklich lang
geguckt
ist mehrung das ist einfach eigentlich gar nicht so einfach Former
muss ich mal aufcoolern
komm schon
dr
wie viele leute
es ist wie to play nicht dass mich das stören würde also interessiert mich einfach nur weil
ich glaube die meisten dieser spiele die die können sich fast nicht mehr erlauben heutzutage
nicht free to play zu sein mit skins das dachte ich mir das dachte ich mir das stimmt das stimmt
du kannst battlefield 3 und battlefield 4 heute spielen max settings ultra wide hd volle details
240 fps und läuft gut und man muss sagen ich finde die spiele sehen heute immer noch brauchbar
aus jetzt nicht so dass du dir battlefield 3 anguckt und ihr denkst du das schönste spiel
aller zeiten aber das sieht schon noch also ich finde battlefield 3 hat eine gerade auch aus der
heutigen zeit betrachtet hat eine super ist ein super kompromiss aus optik und performance gerade
auch gerade auf heutigen rechten
an lutscht das einfach so krass 240 plus fps in 16 k so nach dem motto volle details und es sieht
immer noch ganz okay aus das beste an battlefield 3 so im nachhinein waren immer noch die ganzen
voice coms von den soldaten ich glaube würden die heute battlefield 3 voice coms machen die
leute werden so des todes getriggert das kannst du heute das kannst du heute
nimmer bringen die würden alle ausrasten gute art style altert immer gut es ist da ist was dran
für mich persönlich habe ich auch schon öfters gesagt sehen super nintendo spiele immer noch
toll aus und super nintendo spiele sind ja nun wirklich wenn du das mit heutiger technik
vergleicht halt sehr minimalistisch ja aber dafür dass halt der vorteil von 2d handgepixelt versus 3d gerendert
aber das ist halt der vorteil von 2d handgepixelt versus 3d gerendert
und ich muss halt sagen vielleicht liegt es auch daran weil ich damit aufgewachsen bin aber
ich kann wind weger war ja windwege es auch durch die ganze szene geschichte gut gealtert obwohl es
damals gar nicht so gut angekommen ist wegen dem töl schädigen look es gab ja vorher diese quasi
gamecube selda de mo die im realistischen look und alle erwartet dass das spiel kommt was so aussieht
dann kam halt wind weger viel leute gesagt oh okay damit ist alles nah da hat mich alles gut zugefallen
was das aber hinterher ist gut geil die hd variante von windbreaker auf der wii
der mit ihm auch optisch sehr nice aber bei mir ist es halt so ich muss sagen
ich kann 2d sprites und 2d 2 2d pixel sachen irgendwie mehr die emotionen
abnehmen als 3d models schwer zu sagen warum vielleicht weil man da mehr
vorstellungskraft braucht anstatt dass man es sieht weiß nicht naja chat was
war denn heute ich habe ich habe mir nichts ich habe mir nichts überlegt ich
bin eigentlich nur angekommen um euch zu sagen dass ich absolut keinen bock habe
besser gesagt dass ich kein hab kein bock keck weh habe ja morgen wieder
arbeiten zu gehen das ist das ist legit der einzige grund
warum ich warum ich angekommen bin jetzt habe ich euch das gesagt könnte ich
eigentlich auch wieder aufgeben was mache ich nicht
aber ich habe mir ich habe mir nichts überlegt ich wollte das einfach nur mal
loswerden dass ich keinen bock habe das wollte ich mir nur angucken richtig ja
habe ich sogar schon offen hast du dich schon mal du meinst diesem video
recordings oder kamera recordings ding beschäftigt ist zu viel gesagt ich habe
das mal in irgendeinem container gestartet und festgestellt dass das
irgendwie nichts per web rtc überträgt und ich ja hauptsächlich angucken will
und nicht
aufnehmen will insofern hat sich das dann für mich erledigt du hast auch so
richtigen chatte wer von euch muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen
ich meine ich gehe mal davon aus die meisten von euch werden frei gehabt haben
zumindest mal heute gestern vorgestern das wochenende und und heute nehmen uns
nicht
ok
falls lernen auch zählt musst du dazu das haus verlassen zum lernen
nee dann zählt nicht am 16 wieder sehr schön nice und an alle die morgen
wieder arbeiten müssen wie viel bock habt ihr wieder arbeiten zu gehen
könntest du mal eine stellenanzeige review und mir sagen was du davon hältst
auf indeed die stellenanzeige von first colo gmbh datencenter in frankfurt
nation ist das thema schickt einen link kann ich mal gucken wir haben doch
sogar hier noch irgendeine die ich bin auch noch angucken sollte oder wolf eu
die hatte ich schon so lange offen die habe ich das letzte mal gesagt gucke ich
mir an habe ich dann nie gemacht urlaub bock du freust dich richtig
ich lese daraus dass du dich eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht freust aber so was
ist in geschriebener form immer schwer zu interpretieren
ja ja das link posten doch ist ernst gemeint alter ich finde es
wahrscheinlich morgen auch gar nicht so schlecht wenn ich mir erst mal da bin
uns losgeht aber so immer vorbereitungstechnisch so also nie also
gedanken technisch das jetzt da wieder los geht aber ich habe ich habe ich keinen
bock dran du hast kein link gepostet zur stellenanzeige oder sondern woanders ok
wir wollen nicht weiter mit google
und wir haben deine und wir haben deine die aus irgendwelchen gründen weiß ich
ob das jetzt schlechtes welches auch das hier doch ok aber wenn ich muss das mal
kurz körper kopieren weil mich das ziemlich blendet also wisst ihr was das
erste ist was ich morgen mache ich schließe mein notebook an und lasst
erstmal die ganzen updates daran laufen da ist der halbe tag schon warum weil
ich hatte den des dezember ich hatte den ganzen dezember nicht an habe
gar nicht mehr gelesen ich hatte den ganzen dezember nicht an habe gar nicht
keine updates bekommen als im endeffekt morgen erst mal halben tag notebook
update ist okay wir wollen das so da mache ich das
stand da eben nicht noch mehr da wie klein möchte man das bitte einer die ist
ja die ist ja mies diese webseite what the fuck er macht denn solche webseiten
alter
was das indeed so was suchen die denn die suchen einen junior systemadministrator
alles klar zum teil im home office ist immer manchen unternehmen also ich kenne
alles klar zum teil im home office ist immer manchen unternehmen also ich kenne die nicht ich sag's einfach nur bei
die nicht ich sag's einfach nur bei
die nicht ich sag's einfach nur bei manchen unternehmen habe ich den eindruck
manchen unternehmen habe ich den eindruck
manchen unternehmen habe ich den eindruck die machen da mittlerweile einfach nur
die machen da mittlerweile einfach nur
die machen da mittlerweile einfach nur das häkchen dass die leute überhaupt
das häkchen dass die leute überhaupt
das häkchen dass die leute überhaupt reingucken und am ende steht dann sowas
was wie, nur nach Absprache mit dem
Vorgesetzten und dann will es der
Vorgesetzte nicht.
Bereitschaftsdienst, ja.
Ist schon okay.
Okay.
First Kolo
ist ein Betreiber von...
Okay, das lesen wir uns nicht durch.
Das ist wieder die übliche Selbstbeweihräucherung,
die vor jeder Stellenanzeige kommt.
Ich kenne die. Mir kommt der Name
bekannt vor. Ich habe das schon mal gehört.
First Kolo.
Das kenne ich.
Haben die... Moment, lasst uns mal kurz
auf den ihrer Webseite gucken,
an welchen Standorten die in Frankfurt
sind. Standorte.
Hanauer Landstraße. Habe ich das gerade schon da was
gesehen? Ja.
Das ist durchaus möglich, dass ich
die da schon... Gut,
das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Accelerated.
Das sagt mir auch irgendwas.
Aber Hanauer Landstraße
ist durchaus möglich. Da ist ja der DZX dann
auch nicht weit. Aber die habe ich schon mal
gehört. Gesehen will ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber gehört.
Auf jeden Fall schon.
Ist aber auch durchaus möglich, dass ich da irgendwann schon mal
drin war. Ich bin
mir echt nicht sicher.
Also Hanauer Landstraße war ich schon an einigen.
In der Kleierstraße war ich auch schon in einigen.
In...
Wie hieß das andere?
Das war jetzt zumindest die einzigen zwei, die mir so
aus dem Kopf einfallen. Und da hast du ja auch, wo du
hinspuckst.
Rechenzentrumsanbieter.
Also gehört habe ich den Namen auf jeden Fall
schon mal. Schon drin, aber weiß ich nicht.
Kann aber sein.
Also.
Aufgaben.
Als Teil von Managed Service...
Als Teil von...
Soll das nicht als Teil von Managed Services
heißen, oder?
Ach nee. Ach nee. Managed Service.
Das Team heißt Managed Service.
Ach so. Als Teil...
Als Teil von Managed Service
bist du mit dem Tagesgeschäft
betraut und kümmerst dich um die Konzipierung,
der Kundeninfrastruktur. Ja, gut.
Du liebst
abwechslungsreiches Arbeiten und suchst
die Herausforderungen in unterschiedlichen Bereichen.
Bei uns
konzeptionierst,
administrierst und
verantwortest du eigene
Serverlandschaften und Kundeninfrastrukturen.
Okay?
Du bist wissbegierig und aufgeschlossen.
Unsere Kollegen führen dich an neue Technologien
heran.
Insider-Fachabteilung. Okay, das ist beides
unglaublich nicht zu handfinden.
Okay.
Es ist so, wie sehr möchtest du
umschreiben, was du wirklich machst?
Du scheuerst dich...
Moment. Nein. Du scheust
dich nicht. Ja, scheuern
vielleicht auch. Weil bei
Kundengesprächen scheuer ich mich davor.
Du scheuerst dich nicht vor
Kundengesprächen. Du unterstützt deine Kollegen
bei Kundenbetreuung
und stehst ihnen
bei Rückfragen und der Angebotsgestaltung
zur Seite.
Okay. Also ich scheue
mich vor Kundengesprächen.
Also wenn das Endkunden sind.
Was wahrscheinlich ist.
Da hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Endkundengespräch ist immer ganz abartig.
Muss dich glücklicherweise nie großartig machen.
Du bist neugierig.
Wir betreiben mehrere Virtualisierungsplattformen.
Proxmox, Kubernetes und
VMware. Auch ein
OpenStack und ZEV mit einigen IP-Tab...
Das ist okay. Das ist
eine wilde Mischung. VMware,
Proxmox, Kubernetes
und OpenStack.
Wir machen einfach mal alles.
ZEV ist ja noch
was anderes. ZEV als
Distributed Storage.
Wie spricht man einen Rechtschreibfehler
in einer Stellenanzeige an? Gar nicht.
Ja, genau das würde ich auch
sagen. Gar nicht.
Das ist so ein typischer Fall von
Wie soll ich sagen?
Also
Es juckt einen vielleicht, da mal klug
zu scheißen, aber
auch wenn man sich jetzt denken könnte,
sie müssten sich darüber freuen,
auf Fehler hingewiesen zu werden, ist die Chance,
dass sie sich nicht darüber freuen.
Höher.
Deswegen, ich würde einfach gar nichts dazu
sagen. So, Anforderungen.
Was wollen sie haben?
Sie suchen, wohlgemerkt,
sie suchen einen Junior. Also mal gucken, ob das
passt. Du bringst
erste Erfahrung in der Linux-Administration mit.
Du solltest nicht auf eine
Linux-Distribution limitiert
sein. Wir setzen
vorwiegend Debian und
Jubantu-basierte Systeme
ein.
Oh,
nice. Debian ist schon mal
richtige Wahl.
Und über
kann man sich streiten,
aber gerade im Cloud- und im Enterprise-Sektor,
wenn es nicht Ratted ist,
dann ist es halt nur mal
öfters Ubuntu. Manche
Verrückte machen auch Suse, aber wer macht denn sowas?
Du bist dir
unsicher, ob du ausreichend Erfahrung hast.
Bewirb dich für das Gemeinsame heraus.
Da wirst du dann gefragt, wie kommst du aus
Wim raus oder sowas?
Du hast Interesse, dich in neue
Technologien selbstständig in unsere Einladung
einzuarbeiten.
Wir stellen Infrastrukturen von
einfachen Web-Servern und Datenbank-Servern über
redundante Web-Stacks bis hin zu
kompletten und mehrfach redundanten
Virtualisierungs-Umgebungen für unsere Kunden zur Verfügung.
Du bist kommunikationsstark.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Was fällt euch noch an?
Was fällt euch noch ein? Doppelpunkt Q?
Doppelpunkt WQ?
Richtig, da warte ich immer drauf.
Da warte ich, weil nur die echten Hackermans
wissen, dass man Wim mit Shift-ZZ beenden kann.
PS-Aug-Skript
Wim, Kill-Wim, P-Kill-Wim.
Das zählt nicht.
Ich sag doch, nur echte Hackermans
wissen, dass das das geht.
Sehr gut.
Doppelpunkt X geht im Zweifelsfall auch noch,
wenn ihr schreiben wollt.
Weil Doppelpunkt X und Doppelpunkt WQ das gleiche ist.
Was darf man sich darunter vorstellen?
Du bist kommunikationsstark.
Das ist eine Redewendung,
die sehe ich total oft, aber was konkret?
Wollen die damit eigentlich sagen?
Ich hab wieder den Eindruck,
das ist so eine coole Redewendung,
die da reingeschrieben wird,
aber die haben sich selbst gar keine genauen Gedanken
darüber gemacht, was die eigentlich wollen.
Rumgeschreien.
Das meinen sie wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Aber das könnte man da auch reininterpretieren.
Die meinen damit wahrscheinlich,
dass du quasi, soll ich sowas sagen,
klar und sicher mit anderen Leuten
kommunizieren kannst, was jetzt Sache ist.
Aber es ist echt,
ich kann mir da immer nichts unterscheiden,
was ich mir an solchen Umschreibungen vorstellen.
Dass du dich gut ausdrücken kannst in den Meetings
oder mit Kunden vernünftig reden kannst.
Ja, siehste, Blue Sky.
Genau das ist das, was ich mir da so darunter vorstellen würde,
umschrieben.
Aber immer sehr schwierig,
weil das Interpretation...
Kann man das nicht irgendwie so reinschreiben?
Ich meine vielleicht nicht so, wie es jetzt direkt
bei dir aus der Tastatur gerade geflossen ist.
Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
so dass man das da
ohne viel Interpretation rauslesen kann.
Ohne viel Interpretation rauslesen kann.
Okay, nice, also.
Gute Englischkenntnisse sind
wünschenswert. Easy.
Du arbeitest
sorgfältig und bist mit...
und bist dir der Verantwortung
für den Infrastruktur unserer Kunden bewusst.
Du bist ein Teamplayer. Dein Team kann sich auf deine Zuverlässigkeit
verlassen. Du unterstützt das Team
im Rahmen der extra vergüteten Rufbereitschaft.
Oh ja!
Rufbereitschaft muss ich glaube ich auch
einmal am Wochenende diesen Monat wieder machen.
Da gibt's wieder...
Das ist so heftig, ne?
Ihr müsst euch jetzt mal
die Ohren zuhalten, weil das teilweise
schon echt...
Es grenzt fast schon an
Gelddruckmaschine für
wenig bis nichts arbeiten viel Geld
bekommen. Bei uns bekommst
du knapp, knapp, das ist ein bisschen
weniger, es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, von wann bis wann,
aber aufgerundet knapp
1000 Euro
für Rufbereitschaft
am Wochenende. Das ist so krass, Alter!
Da musst du natürlich
noch Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Wir reden jetzt nicht, dass du das überwiesen kriegst.
Es ist so heftig.
Rufbereitschaft...
Also Moment, mehr als das ganze
Wochenende. Rufbereitschaft ist
Freitag 17 Uhr
bis Montags 8 Uhr.
Dann kriegst du
ungefähr 1000 Euro.
Doch, ich bezahl Steuern drauf,
da krieg ich Rentenpunkte.
Mir wäre es aber lieber,
das wäre steuerfrei.
24,7.
Sicher auch Abgaben?
Nein, nicht sicher.
Aber wie kontaktieren die dich,
wenn du pennst?
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Erste Eskalationsstufe ist
Message.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, über welchen Kanal die reinkommen.
Message aufs Handy.
Da musst du halt dein Handy laut lassen nachts.
Dann macht es dann blim, blim
oder was auch immer du für SMS einschlägst.
Wenn du es eingestellt hast
und das Handy laut hast.
Erste Eskalationsstufe ist
ich nenn es mal SMS.
Zweite Eskalationsstufe ist
dich ruft irgendeiner an.
Ich bekomme das mit.
Bekomme das mit.
Zweite Eskalationsstufe ist
du wirst angerufen.
Sollte irgendwas sein
und sogar schon die Leute,
die für die eigentliche Anwendung zuständig sind
das mitbekommen haben,
dann rufen die dich auch an.
Das heißt,
wenn du nachts rein musstest.
Rein nicht, aber einloggen nachts.
Das gab es schon.
Besonders geil, wenn man neu ist
und die ganzen Systeme nicht kennt.
Und das witzige bei uns ist halt
die Leute, die sich für die Systeme
zuständig sind,
die kennen die.
Die anderen kennen sie eigentlich alle
mehr oder weniger nicht sonderlich gut.
Und ich kenne die meisten halt gar nicht richtig.
Außer meine.
Ich habe immer große Planlosigkeit angesagt,
wenn da was kommt an SMS.
Ich habe auch schon nachts Nachrichten gekriegt.
Da sind dann so Meldungen drin wie
Check MK empfängt keine Daten mehr.
Und da denke ich mir,
What the fuck, Check MK empfängt keine Daten mehr.
Was juckt's mich?
Aber oftmals deutet das halt auf was hin,
dass irgendwas größeres kaputt ist.
Muss man nach dem Anruf instant
bzw. nach der Nachricht instant verfügbar sein
Du hast Zeit.
Umso schneller, umso besser.
Aber du hast eine gewisse Zeit.
Also du musst nicht instant verfügbar sein.
Instant gibt es ja eh nicht.
5 Minuten wäre für mich instant.
Es ist mehr als 5 Minuten.
Also du hast durchaus Zeit,
wenn du gerade
beim EDK bist
und noch 20 Minuten
heimlaufen musst.
Abends oder so.
Dann ist das im Rahmen.
Kein Problem.
So kann man die Stellenanzeige fertig machen.
Nicht die hier, die andere.
Du bist ein Teamplayer.
Dein Team kann sich auf deine Zuverlässigkeit verlassen.
Du unterstützt das Team.
Okay, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Deine Vorteile.
Flexiblen sind die flexiblen Arbeitszeiten.
Gestalte deinen Arbeitstag.
Okay.
Das liest sich immer gut.
Es ist komplett
Interpretationssache,
wie es dann gelebt wird.
Also das heißt jetzt erstmal gar nichts.
Du hast deine Ausbildung,
du investierst in das.
Ja, okay.
Hybrides Arbeiten.
Genieße die Freiheit, sowohl im Büro als auch remote
zur Arbeit maximale Flexibilität zu erleben.
Liest sich auch gut.
Wie es dann praktisch aussieht,
weiß man halt nicht.
Respekt und Wertschätzung.
Bei uns steht nicht nur die Arbeit
im Mittelpunkt,
sondern auch der Mensch.
Wenn die jetzt was anfangen
von Familie zu erzählen.
Okay.
Das ist alles für die hohle Hand,
wie es wichtig ist,
wie es intern auch wirklich gelebt wird
oder gemacht wird.
Mitarbeiter Events.
Tauche in unsere Teamkultur ein.
Sei es bei Teambuilding,
Aktivitäten, Firmenausflügen
und gemeinsamen Feierlichkeiten.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten.
Gesundheitsförderung.
Wir legen Wert auf.
Sportangebote, Fitnesskurse,
leckeres Mittagessen.
Genieße zweimal pro Woche
köstliche Mahlzeiten, während
ich mit deinen Kollegen austausche.
Kann ich die auch genießen,
ohne mich auszutauschen dabei?
Einfach nur fressen und wieder arbeiten gehen?
Oder ist das so ein Event,
wo du nur hingehen kannst,
wenn du auch richtig krass socializest dabei?
Vielfältige Verfügungsmöglichkeiten.
Genieße eine riesige Auswahl an Getränken,
Snacks, darunter Müsli von MyMüsli.
Schon nie gehört.
Was ist MyMüsli?
Lieblingsmüsli, aha.
Ich esse nur Müsli von
Seitenbacher.
Nee, ich esse gar kein Müsli.
Leckere Joghurts und vieles mehr.
Ah ja.
Wer war das, der das geschickt hat?
Ja, Marc.
Ich finde die Stellanzeige
geht in Ordnung.
Die ist zwar nichts herausragendes
jetzt, wo man sagen wird,
boah, da waren sie aber super krass kreativ.
Oder, boah, das habe ich aber noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist so im Bereich, wo ich mir denke,
ja, der Laden könnte durchaus was taugen.
Wissen anhand der Stellanzeige
kann man es nicht.
Ich würde aber nicht sagen,
es sieht offensichtlich kacke aus.
Es sieht halt sehr 0815 aus.
Finde ich.
Der Laden kann super sein.
Kann auch nichts taugen.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Wir können es ja nur anhand der Stellanzeige hier bewerten.
Genauso wie die Unternehmen das immer nur
bei uns anhand der Bewerbung bewerten können.
Ziemlich Standard,
würde ich sagen.
Chat, was denkt ihr?
Also, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach recht 0815.
Ja, 0815
HR-Abteilung.
Genauso liest sich auch.
Ja, ziemlich Standard.
Das Müsli von
Seitenbacher, genau.
Teambuilding.
Ich war im Dezember,
im letzten Oktober
war das, letzte Oktobertage.
Nicht Oktober, Novembertage
war ich ja auch auf dem Teambuilding-Workshop.
Der ging halbwegs klar.
Ich hab da kein Geheimnis drum gemacht,
dass ich eigentlich keinen Bock hab, aber
der ging schon irgendwie halbwegs klar.
Zwischenzeitlich las es sich
ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen wie
ergänzt durch Chat-GPT.
Nicht geschrieben komplett durch Chat-GPT,
aber es las sich auf jeden Fall ergänzt durch Chat-GPT.
Das trifft's,
das fasst eigentlich ganz gut zusammen.
Sieht halt aus wie ein Job.
Ja.
Okay.
Hab ich eigentlich jetzt schon
Package-Updates hier gemacht?
Ja, gell?
Okay.
Wir wollten uns da noch irgendwas angucken.
Lasst uns doch jetzt gerade, dass wir's noch hinkriegen.
Chat-GPT, ist derjenige da,
der diese Stellenanzeige gepostet hat?
Irgendjemand wollte, dass wir uns das hier angucken?
Ich hab's seit drei Wochen oder so nicht geschafft.
Wahrscheinlich schon mittlerweile längst
die Bewerbung raus oder abgelehnt
oder Job schon bekommen oder was auch immer.
Wir können uns aber nochmal
schnell angucken.
Also,
wer haben wir denn hier?
Wolf.eu
Deine Tätigkeit, was suchen sie denn?
Sie suchen einen IT-Administrator.
Administration, Erweiterung und Wartung
von zentralen wie dezentralen Betrieben
im Server- und Netzwerksystem.
Okay, das ist super allgemein.
Das ist wirklich, also
mehr allgemein beschreiben kann man
die Tätigkeit eigentlich kaum.
Konzeptionierung, Konfiguration
und Betrieb von IT-Infrastruktur
mit Fokus auf...
Da wäre ich jetzt schon raus an der Stelle.
Ich suche zwar nichts, aber ich wäre schon
an der Stelle raus.
Keck Microsoft, Alter.
Analyse und Lösung
von Applikationsbetriebssystem
und Datenbankproblem.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen minimal konkreter.
Kann aber auch immer noch alles sein.
Weil alles ist irgendwie ein Applikationsbetriebssystem
oder Datenbankproblem.
Mitwirkung bei
Projekten, Definition des Zielsystems.
Was?
Mitwirkung bei Projekten,
soweit verstehe ich noch.
Was ist Definition des Zielsystems?
Was meinen die damit, Chat?
Seid mal kreativ.
Was könnte damit gemeint sein?
Die meinen damit
bestimmt nicht, verwenden wir Red Hat
oder Ubuntu oder Debian.
Also, wisst's auch nicht.
Mitwirkung und Steuerung der Umsetzung
an verschiedenen Standorten.
Da kann man sich jetzt schon...
Also Mitwirkung, ja, ob Steuerung
in dem Aufgabenbereich von einem Admin gefällt,
kann man sich echt drüber streiten.
Auf welcher Kiste das laufen soll?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das damit gemeint ist.
Zusammenarbeit mit internen Teams.
Backup.
Verwaltung der Benutzeridentität
und Zugriff auf IT-Systeme. Alles klar.
Behebungsabläufe.
Okay, auch alles klar.
Abgeschlossen. Was wollen sie haben?
Übliche Geschichte, Ausbildung oder Studium
oder bla bla.
Mehrjährige Berufserfahrung im Bereich IT-Support
MonkaS.
Oder IT-Systemintegration.
Lösungsorientierte
analytische Arbeitsweise,
vertiefte Kenntnisse,
Server-Client-Computing.
Das ist auch sehr weit
gefasst.
Virtualisierung.
Also da hat auf jeden Fall
die Abteilung, die das Ding geschrieben hat,
wieder nicht genau
verstanden oder wusste,
oder?
Bei einem oder mehreren der folgenden Punkte
bringst du bereits eine große Erfahrungsschatz mit.
Windows Server, VMware, Commvault.
Kenne ich nicht. VDI.
Also sagt mir wenigstens was, was es ist.
Commvault habe ich noch nie gehört, VMware klar.
Habe ich aber auch keine große Erfahrung mit.
Windows Server will ich gar keine Erfahrung mit haben.
Was ist Commvault?
Data Protection against Cyber Threats.
Excellent.
Okay, die kommen aus den USA.
Dann ist alles Cyber Threat,
wenn ich nicht die NSA ist.
Erfahrung im Bereich Server-Virtualisierung.
Okay, die wollen es aber echt wissen
mit Server-Virtualisierung, oder?
Vertiefte Kenntnisse im Bereich
Virtualisierung, VMware.
Erfahrung im Bereich Virtualisierung.
Leute, glaubt ihr, die wollen jemanden,
der schon mal was virtualisiert hat?
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Könnte sein, vielleicht.
Hohes Maß an Teamfähigkeit,
Flexibilität.
Am Ende nutzen sie Hyper-V.
Aber ich stehe zumindest vor VMware drin.
Selbstständige Überzeugungskraft
und Durchsetzungsformen
sowie interkulturelle
Kompetenz.
Was?
Da kann ich mir zum Beispiel schon mal gar nichts darunter vorstellen.
Was ist interkulturelle Kompetenz?
Ah, ich weiß es!
Die haben was outgesourcet nach Indien.
Die haben 100 pro was
outgesourcet nach Indien oder Rumänien
oder Dubai oder wo auch immer
man was hin outsourcet.
Und das meinen die bestimmt.
Dass du dann auch mit denen
klarkommst.
Sehr gute deutsche und englische Kenntnisse.
Microsoft Gold Support.
Großer fachlicher
Freiraum.
Ja,
liest sich auch sehr 0815.
Also wer auch immer das gepostet hat,
kann man jetzt nicht wirklich daran
ableiten, ob die besonders gut oder besonders schlecht
sind. Ist sehr 0815
Standard Zeug.
Das glaube ich
in dem Fall nicht. Das würde ich, das
könnte man so aus dem Bauchgefühl
mäßig da vielleicht reininterpretieren.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, das glaube ich nicht,
dass sowas
selbst, wenn das
der Fall wäre, irgendwie den Weg
in die Stellanzeige finden würde.
Realistischer ist, sie haben einiges
outgesourcet und du musst
klarkommen mit, wenn du mit Leuten aus
Indien telefonierst, dass die vielleicht ein bisschen anders
ticken. Vielleicht gab es ja da in der Vergangenheit schon
öfters Probleme mit. In der Zusammenarbeit
mit dem outgesourceten Kram nach Indien.
Was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann.
Ja, also ich gehe eher
davon aus, dass das was
ist, weil sie irgendwas outgesourcet
haben. Oder was heißt
outgesourcet? Muss ja nicht mal outgesourcet sein.
Kann ja auch sein, dass das
tatsächlich zum Laden gehört,
aber halt hauptsächlich woanders
old on, old on.
Oder eingesourcet,
ja. Ich habe jetzt
schon gehört, dass man im
Managerspeak nicht mehr
outgesourcet sagt,
sondern, und auch nicht,
also es gab mal einen Trend, da hat man
outgesourcet gesagt. Dann gab es,
dann hat man gesagt offshore
oder sowas. Und mittlerweile
sagt man nearshoring.
Das ist ein anderes Wort für,
es ist halt EU-Ausland,
wo man das outgesourcet hat.
Man hat es aber nicht outgesourcet, sondern man hat es
nearshoring.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das überhaupt richtig
Sätze bilden soll damit.
Am Managerspeak ändert sich ja auch
immer ein bisschen.
Nearshoring.
Funktioniert es ja auch zum
Funktioniert es ja auch zum größten Teil nicht.
Deswegen ist diese ganze Outsourcing-Geschichte
gar nicht mehr so
im Trend.
Mich würde interessieren, wie breit du das Tätigkeitsspektrum
eines IT-Admins siehst, also für
für wie viel ein Admin
Zuständigkeit sein soll.
Das Spektrum ist enorm breit, weil an vielen
Stellen Admin draufsteht und die überhaupt
keine Admin sind.
So nach dem Motto, ja, die
keine Ahnung, die
Abmachung mit dem Betriebsrat sieht halt
vor, dass es nur Adminstellen gibt
in dem und dem Bereich, aber eigentlich brauchen wir
gar keine Admins, sondern
Cloud-Infrastruktur-Leute, DevOps-Leute
und Admins und hast du nicht gesehen,
die haben halt alle dann den Titel Admin.
Hab ich auch schon gesehen und insofern
enorm breit.
Weil es nicht zwangsläufig ein
Administrator sein muss, nur weil Administrator dransteht.
Viel wichtiger ist, was du
konkret da für Tätigkeitsfelder, die
definiert hast. Alles
Cloud. Ja und Leute, denkt dran,
denkt dran, nicht Cloud-Anbieter
oder gar Cloud-Provider, sondern Hyperscaler.
Mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn es Unternehmen gibt,
wo Admins Full-Stack-Entwickler
sind oder beziehungsweise Full-Stack-Entwickler
auf ihrer
in ihrer Personalakte
ein Admin drinstehen haben.
Nein, war ich nicht, war ich nicht.
Ich wollte mir, ich hab mir ein paar Talks
gespeichert, ich mir angucken wollte,
aber
hab ich noch nicht einen reingeschaut bisher.
Einer hatte einen Talk
drüber über Sicherheitslücken
bei...
Ach, da hat mich die Überschrift schon angesprochen.
Ich hab's vergessen.
Sicherheitslücken bei...
Irgendwas, wo ich mir gedacht hab.
In alten Games.
In alten Multiplayer-Games.
So nach dem Motto Remote Code Execution
mit alten Multiplayer-Games.
Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Hab ich letztens in den YouTube-Empfehlungen gehabt.
Ich glaub das...
Wurde dort
gepräsentated.
Wie in CS.
Wieso hatte CS da Probleme in der Richtung?
Und CS ist ja wirklich
jetzt...
Hatte CS?
Inwiefern? Das hab ich gar nicht
glaub nicht mitbekommen.
CS2 has found a bug
that can be used to steal personal data.
Ja.
Geil.
Nicht sanitized HTML in Vault-Kick-Fenster.
Es sind aber auch immer die Basics,
die nicht hinhauen, oder?
Oh man.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass solche offensichtlichen Dinger...
Leute, und soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Weil wir es gerade letztens davon hatten.
Mit Rust wäre das auch passiert.
Da kann Rust überhaupt nichts dran ändern.
Oh, guck mal.
Mein Kanal.
Schade, morgen in meine neue Stelle als Software-Developer
rein mit plus 20 mehr Gehalt.
Excellent. Und hast du Bock, morgen anzufangen?
Weil die Sache bei mir ist,
ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock, wieder arbeiten zu müssen,
morgen.
Du bist gehypt. Okay.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, als ich im April
angefangen hab, war ich so...
Die ersten Wochen
auch gehypt.
Weil es halt einfach was Neues war.
Mittlerweile hab ich mich schon wieder ganz gut dran gewöhnt.
Der Hype ist abgeklungen.
Ja.
Wenig.
Wir haben ein paar...
Ich hab vorhin im Chat gefragt,
und da haben ein paar Leute gesagt,
sie freuen sich tatsächlich richtig drauf, morgen.
Konnte ich nicht nachvollziehen,
aber ich mein, jeder, wo er Bock drauf hat, ja.
100% Remote bin immer noch gehypt.
Ja, kann man auch.
100% Remote ist
POG.
Ich hoffe, die bezahlen das auch richtig gut.
Weil dann wäre es doppelt POG.
Das Problem hab ich in der Tat nicht.
Das ist jetzt nur,
weil ich quasi einen Monat daheim
gesessen hab und Kreisel-Crime gemacht hab.
Da ich keinen Bock hab.
Wie gesagt,
ich mach ja auch ne 4-Tage-Woche
und ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme mehr.
Montags hab ich ja übrigens frei.
Dienstags dann wieder anzufangen.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich kann übrigens nach wie vor jedem
nur wärmstens empfehlen, sich das zu überlegen.
Gerade für alle, die in der IT arbeiten
und eben mehr als genug Kohle verdienen.
Ich kann das euch allen wärmstens nur empfehlen.
Überlegt euch mal,
ob 4-Tage-Woche nicht was für euch ist.
Nein, nicht BDO.
Nicht BDO.
Eine 2-Tage-Woche wär POG-Champ.
Leute, wisst ihr,
was ich mir letztens überlegt hab?
Es gibt ja immer mehr Diskussionen darüber,
ob jetzt nicht
die 4-Tage-Woche eingeführt werden soll.
Also, ich persönlich geh davon aus,
dass es kein Unternehmen freiwillig macht.
Weil es sich wieder irgendwie nicht traut.
Gerade in Deutschland, so moderne Sachen,
das wird nix.
Aber wenn die ne 4-Tage-Woche einführen
und sollten die bei mir, dort wo ich arbeite,
niemals eine 4-Tage-Woche für alle einführen,
wohlgemerkt,
bei gleichbleibender Bezahlung,
das ist ja das, was hier teilweise diskutiert wird,
dann werde ich zur 3-Tage-Woche wechseln.
Wenn es sich natürlich um
4-Tage-Woche handelt,
die 2 Stunden
mehr am Tag bedeuten,
da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Aber wenn das wirklich kommt bei uns,
dann würde ich,
dann habe ich 2 Sachen zur Auswahl.
Entweder
ich bekomme einfach 20% mehr Geld,
weil ja alle
von 5 Tagen auf 4 Tage
war gleich eine Bezahlung,
oder ich gehe einfach runter auf 3 Tage
und dann,
das wäre mir ja fast noch lieber,
keck weight.
Am besten, Leute,
ich bin nächstes Jahr 40,
am besten ich gehe gleich in Altersteilzeit, oder?
Was meint ihr?
Soll ich in Altersteilzeit gehen schon?
Ich glaube mit 39, knapp 40,
kann man sich das schon mal überlegen.
Aber das ist ja auch Zeit,
ja, denke ich auch.
0 Tage und trotzdem bezahlt,
das würde natürlich jeder nehmen.
Mein ETF geht richtig big stonks
seit
2 Monaten oder so.
Lass mich gerade mal kurz gucken.
Es wurde jetzt zwar nicht gehandelt,
die letzten Tage, aber ich habe jetzt schon
eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Loggen Sie sich ein, Alter, Scalable geht mir auf den Sack.
Ja, ich logge mich ein, ist gut.
Boah, die Stonks gehen echt gut, gut rauf.
Ich würde das ohne Probleme machen,
100% Remote.
Ich finde es aber auch in Ordnung,
wenn die sagen, 100% Remote wollen sie nicht.
Der nächste Standort ist noch nicht so weit weg,
ein Tag die Woche, so wie es bei mir aktuell ist.
Habe ich auch keine Probleme damit.
Hätte ich auch beim letzten Laden keine Probleme gehabt,
hätten die da nicht darauf bestanden,
so nach dem Motto, alle wieder in die Firma
und so Zeug, dann
wäre ich da wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht weg
beim alten Laden.
Paysafe?
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde keine random
Ausweisfotos und sonstige
Sachen schicken.
Das wollten auch schon einige Hosting-Anbieter
von mir, nachdem ich mich registriert habe.
Unter anderem
auch,
ich weiß nicht, wer es war,
Netcup war es, glaube ich.
Da habe ich eine Werbung gesehen
von denen auf Twitter und habe darauf geantwortet,
ich würde es ja gerne bei euch wieder ausprobieren,
aber muss ich immer noch meinen Ausweis einscannen?
Wie wäre es denn mit so etwas wie Postident?
Dann meinten sie, nein, leider ist es nicht mit Postident möglich
und Ausweis einscannen.
Gut, dann halt
nichts für mich.
Wie wichtig ist heutzutage ein Master
im Informatikbereich deiner Meinung nach?
Lohnt sich das?
Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen.
Durchschnittsgehalttechnisch
lohnt sich das sicherlich,
was jetzt aber nicht im Einzelfall
das wusstest du nicht,
dann
sie haben selbst geschrieben auf Twitter,
dass das noch teilweise der Fall ist.
Also,
nicht so als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht.
Hast du Glück gehabt.
Also durchschnittsgehaltstechnisch lohnt sich das,
ob sich jetzt im Einzelfall bei dir lohnt.
Also ich meine,
du kannst auch fette Kohle verdienen,
ohne dass du eine Master in Informatik hast.
Kommt ein bisschen darauf an,
was du machen willst, in welchem Bereich.
Also wenn du zu irgendwelchen Ämtern willst,
die stehen halt unglaublich auf Studium.
Ich kann es schlecht
aus persönlicher Erfahrung beantworten,
weil ich nicht studiert habe.
Aber ich denke,
ich verdiene für uns Studierende auch nicht übel Kohle.
Also,
das kann ich dir nicht beantworten.
Also ich würde sagen,
es ist heute so wenig wie möglich,
äh, so wenig
nötig wie
jemals.
Also es war noch niemals
so wenig nötig wie jetzt.
So, das wollte ich sagen.
Schaden tut's nicht,
ja,
wenn du das machen willst.
Wichtig ist es nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass du was kannst.
Was gesucht wird.
Obol.
Ja gut, 4 Tage Woche,
bei mir ist ja auch nicht nach gleicher Bezahlung,
sondern halt, ich krieg einen Tag weniger Geld,
aber ist vollkommen in Ordnung,
ist immer noch genug Kohle.
Meinst du, dass die überhaupt mit 3 Tagen mitziehen?
Ja, sehr wahrscheinlich.
Weil wir haben einen Betriebsrat
und wir haben sogar Regelungen für Teilzeitarbeit
und ja, das geht.
Ich könnte auch theoretisch auf ganz auf 50%
reduzieren, dann müsste ich nur für
2,5 Tage arbeiten.
Vielleicht sollte ich das echt machen, Leute.
Kohle gibt's
genug und
wenn ich ein bisschen mehr mache,
was Twitch und YouTube angeht, gibt's da auch noch
ganz brauchbar was.
Und dann mehr Kreiselgrind.
Endlich
mehr Zeit für MMO-Kreiselgrind,
meinste.
Ne, ne, das heißt nicht, dass es 50% mehr Max
gibt, das heißt, ich hab mehr Zeit, äh,
den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner zu sitzen und Sachen zu
spielen, aber nicht, dass ich unbedingt mehr streame
oder YouTube-Videos mache. Ihr kennt mich,
wenn ich mir sowas vornehme, wird's nie was.
Was, Bitcoin geht auch ab?
Lass mal kurz gucken, Bitcoin-Kurs, oh.
Naja.
Oh ja, doch, doch.
Oh doch, ist das
Allzeithoch sogar jetzt schon über
40.000 gewesen?
Sorry for Bash, danke für den Sub.
Hör ich schrauf hier?
Ne, 80, 80
40.000 waren Allzeithoch oder so, aber 60?
Ne, 80, dann hab ich's drüber.
Nice.
Ja, wie, wie immer,
ne, nachher
ist man schlauer und denkt sich, na,
hätt ich mir hier mal was geholt, aber
ist halt falsch gedacht.
Du kannst's
halt nicht wissen. Hab mal
eine Frage. Jeff Bezos muss
ins Weltall hier. Der Hypetrend ist
am Start. Du hast nur wenig Zeit,
Leute. Gleich ist's vorbei.
Es ist immer der gleiche, es ist
genauso wie jetzt
Winterschlussverkauf und sowas.
Letztens hab ich sogar noch gehört, letztens
Radiowerbung, ja, manchmal geb ich mir
sowas noch. Es gibt
jetzt einen Winterschlussverkauf
Pre-Sale. Das
ist quasi der Winterschlussverkauf, der
früher anfängt, aber der angeblich schon
schon Pre-Schlussverkauf.
Das ist
einfach nur noch bescheuert mittlerweile. Ich mein,
nach
Black Friday, Black Friday
Week,
Cyber Monday,
Cyber Week,
Christmas Sale,
New Year's Sale wird es... Alter,
es ist ja irgendwann auch mal gut.
Wir glauben euch nicht,
dass ihr uns was schenkt von heute auf
morgen. Wobei, ja, es scheint
ja zu funktionieren. Was wollte
ich... Ach ja, hier. Hab mal eine Frage. Ich
bin... Ich überlege eine Ausbildung
zum Physi zu machen nach dem Abitur.
Wollte aber auch gerne
dual studieren. Ich kenne mehrere
Physis, die erst nach der Ausbildung
noch mal studieren gegangen sind. Was mach ich? Was lohnt sich überhaupt?
Also ganz ehrlich, Physi-Ausbildung
ist halt von der
Schule her easy as fuck.
Da musst du dir überhaupt keine Gedanken
machen. Jeder kann easy
die Physi-Ausbildung schaffen.
Und danach hast du
zumindest ein bisschen praktische Erfahrung.
Beim dualen Studieren halt theoretisch auch,
aber
Studieren ist halt deutlich fordernder
als der
theoretische Teil der Ausbildung.
Also wenn du dich anstrengen willst,
wenn du dich reinhängen willst,
dann studier. Man kommt
heute aber auch ohne Probleme mit einer
mit einer Physi-Ausbildung
klar, wenn man denn Ahnung hat
von dem, was man macht.
Und ja, ich kenne auch einige, die nach der
Physi-Ausbildung studiert haben.
Vielleicht weiß man dann besser, was man
vorhat. Das kann ich dir nicht
beantworten. Ich kenne ehrlich gesagt auch
aus persönlicher Erfahrung die Vor- und Nachteile nicht.
Und ich hab mich mit dualem Studium
auch nie, weil es mich selbst nicht betroffen hat,
wenig beschäftigt. Also
insofern Chat,
vielleicht habt ihr irgendwelche Tipps an MrGaming.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, was du machen sollst.
Außer das, was ich dir schon gesagt hab.
Physi bringt kaum
was fürs Studium. Ne, Physi bringt
nichts fürs Studium. Gar nix.
Aber du hast eine Ausbildung, kannst dann auch Geld verdienen.
Wenn du Ahnung hast.
Hat sich für dich irgendwas im Leben geändert
nach deinem signifikanten Gehaltssprung im letzten
Jahr? Nö.
Weder beim letzten signifikanten
Gehaltssprung noch bei diesem signifikanten
Gehaltssprung. Ich mach genau das gleiche
wie vorher. Ich sitz den ganzen
Tag vorm Rechner
und lass mein Geld
rumliegen und geb davon
nix aus. Und ab und zu
geb ich mal ein bisschen was aus,
weil ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss. Aber ansonsten
bei mir ändert sich da
nix. Ich sag doch
einmal Kellerkind, immer Kellerkind.
Also,
ich glaube,
ich glaube, das wird sich bei mir nie was ändern.
Mich kann man
wenig mit
materiellen Sachen
happy machen.
Also, wie gesagt,
die Sache, wofür ich Geld
ausgebe, ist alle paar Jahre mal
ein ordentlich teurer, neuer Rechner.
Und wenn ich was
haben will, zwischendurch, auch
immer mal wieder. Ja, ich hab mir das Fahrrad gekauft
zum Beispiel.
Oder, ja gut, letztes Jahr hab ich
verstaunlich viel ausgegeben. Letztes Jahr hab ich mir ein Auto
geholt, was ich seit
20 Jahren oder so nicht mehr gemacht hab.
Aber da sieht man mal auch, von welchen
Zeiträumen wir hier reden, ja.
Urlaub juckt mich
gar nicht, Autos juckt mich
gar nicht, irgendwelche
komischen, teuren
Freizeitaktivitäten juckt mich gar nicht.
Ich glaub,
das einzige, was ich letztes Jahr für so
Freizeitsachen ausgegeben hab, also
erstmal mal
Fahrrad und so außen vor,
ja, Fahrrad ist ja auch Freizeit, aber so
so so, just for fun, Freizeitaktivitäten
so, war
das
Iron Maiden Konzert in Frankfurt.
Ich glaub, das war das einzige, wo ich
irgendwie, irgendwie mal hingegangen bin,
wo ich bisschen Kohle für ausgegeben hab.
Das neue Auto
so agil wie das alte, vom Namen her nicht,
vom Auto her schon, und es
ist vor allem deutlich moderner.
Nö, also, wie gesagt, ist nix
geändert. Die Lesung ist
falsch, ja. Bist du bei Microsoft
Gold Support in Indien gelandet wieder?
Sorry for Bash,
Massive Subscription.
xxpainxx, danke schon für den
Sub.
Massive.
Ja, das
ist überall so. Dennis, danke für den Sub.
Benutzt jemand das Tattoo
mit US Layout? Ne.
Da mach ich einen Bogen drum.
Das US Layout hat theoretisch einige
Vorteile, gerade wenn man
Kommandozeilen, WIM-Shortcuts und sowas
verwendet, aber ich hab mich
so sehr an das deutsche Tastaturlayout
seit klein auf gewöhnt, ich kann
da nicht umsteigen. Oder,
ich will nicht sagen, ich kann nicht umsteigen,
es ist eine ganz
gehörige Portion aus, ich will nicht umsteigen,
weil ich keinen Bock traf, mich umzugewöhnen.
Ja, ich weiß, gerade die ganzen
Klammern und so, die du auf ordentlichen Tasten hast
beim US Layout, das macht
schon Sinn, aber ich bin, da bin ich
viel zu faul, da für mich umzugewöhnen.
Jantari, kann es sein, dass du
Daok Eden spielst?
Ich hab jemand gesehen ingame, der hieß fast
genauso. Ne, wahrscheinlich
nicht, wahrscheinlich ist der Name einfach nur
mehrfach, mehrfach belegt.
Kadri, dich hab ich letztens
ingame gesehen, irgendwo.
Ich hab dich geändert?
Wirklich? Bist du
Heiler? Ah ne, Shami.
Kann sein, ja.
Hab ich schon wieder vergessen, ja, aber
wir waren, der Name kommt mir auch bekannt
vor, ich glaub, wir waren irgendwann mal random in irgendeiner
Group, bei irgendwelchen, auch bei
irgendwelchen Raids, wo man random Groups macht,
waren wir garantiert mal in irgendeiner Gruppe, der Name kommt mir
bekannt vor.
Ja.
Nice.
Chatgear. Oh fuck,
Leute, es ist 21.30, ich muss
eine halbe Stunde pennen gehen, morgen muss ich auf die Arbeit.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock auf den
Scheiß, Mann.
Ich weiß, dass es morgen überhaupt nicht schlimm ist,
wenn ich morgen eine halbe Stunde sitze und alles ist wieder wie immer.
Ich kenn das, ja.
Ich mach mir jedes Mal Anfang Januar so,
aber ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, Mann.
Ich sollte echt in
Altersteilzeit gehen, ey.
Gibt's da nicht irgendwie, irgendwie sowas
für Leute wie mich?
Was
wie Altersteilzeit, nur dass
es nicht Altersteilzeit heißt?
Keck?
Keckzeit, oder?
Weiß nicht.
Kann man nicht einfach
24 7 Kreisel grinden
und
trotzdem
fett die Kohle überwiesen bekommen?
Freu dich doch auf wie viele Meetings und alle
fragen erstmal wie es war. Ja, ganz
schlimm, ey. Ganz
schlimm, hab ich am Anfang ja auch schon gesagt.
Bürgergeldzeit.
Auf geht's.
Wie ist das eigentlich
jetzt, wenn man Bürgergeld bekommt, Leute?
Dürfen die einen immer noch
zwingen zu irgendwelchen Maßnahmen
und wenn man da nicht hingeht,
kriegt man, kriegt man das
gestrichen? Oder ist das jetzt vom Tisch?
Denke schon.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Oh, shit.
Nee, dann
will ich kein Bürgergeld, Mann.
Nee, ey,
den Scheiß mach ich nicht.
Den Scheiß mach ich nicht.
Also mit dem Arbeitsamt will ich nie wieder
was zu tun haben, Alter. So ein Kackladen.
Soll jetzt noch schlimmer werden.
Ja, festgestellt, dass sie zu wenig Geld haben.
Wir könnten ja mal, ich hätte da so einen Vorschlag,
wir könnten mal 80%
unserer bürokratischen Hürden
abschaffen, das würde enorm viel Geld sparen.
Kannst du nicht da auch
Gold verkaufen?
Ey, nein.
Das ist ein Free-Shard.
Erstens ist das verboten, zweitens
kauft keiner Free-Shard Gold, zweitens
will ich das nicht und, und
was, witziger Fun-Fact,
in Season 1
hat sogar jemand mal versucht, Gold zu
verkaufen auf einem Free-Shard, Alter.
So wir.
Aber witzig war, den haben sie über, über
erwischt, die, die Mods vom Server
wohl gleich gebannt. Bam.
Bürgergeld Prime.
Ja, da bin ich auch dabei.
Mit Prime-Sub
dabei.
Mit kostenlosem Wubbler-Sub.
So, so hätte ich das gerne.
Ah ja.
Und Chat.
Was war euch sonst so
gewesen die letzten Tage?
Irgendwas, der erwähnenswert ist.
Ich frage jetzt
nur so blöd, weil ich hab jetzt
noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, bevor ich ins Bett muss.
Beziehungsweise bevor ich ausmachen muss.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Also, es gibt, was es gibt. Nein, es gibt eigentlich
nur eine Möglichkeit. Ich bleib jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde
on, weil es lohnt sich nicht eine halbe Stunde
noch irgendwas anderes zu machen.
Du hast dein ESP 32
C3 Super Mini
entdeckt. Ist der C3 das mit dem neuesten
Bluetooth Zeug und ZigBee?
Wie ich ins neue Jahr
gestartet bin, wie immer.
Ich hab gewartet, bis
das Gröbste vom Feuerwerk weg
ist und dann bin ich pennen gegangen.
So ein bisschen wie,
kennt ihr dieses Meme von dem Dicken, der vom Rechner
sitzt und dann
was durchs Fenster scheint und er dann
böse guckt und den
Vorhang zuzieht?
So ungefähr bin ich gestern gewesen.
Ich lieb euch mit
Atschlinux. Ja, Beste.
Willkommen im Club. Du musst es
aber dann auch jedem täglich mehrfach
erzählen.
Was ist denn dein Plan, was da so einsteigerfreundlich ist?
Die sind überhaupt nicht einsteigerfreundlich.
Wayland Desktop sieht echt
mehr...Wayland ist kein Desktop.
Also das ist
alles noch ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ich würde dir
vielleicht nicht unbedingt Atschlinux
zum Einstieg empfehlen, weil das Beste an Atschlinux
finde ich ist,
wenn man es minimal installiert und den Rest selbst
einrichtet. Ja, so wie ich hier
bei mir gemacht hab.
Atschlinux
i3
Westterm
Confix
Also
ich würde dir empfehlen, probier doch mal aus
es ist die Frage, hast du schon Linux
Erfahrung? Wenn du nicht Linux, wenn du keine große
Linux Erfahrung hast, dann nimm Linux Mint
und taste dich da erstmal ein bisschen ran.
Wenn du generell schon Linux Erfahrung
hast und einfach durch ein bisschen Atschlinux rantasten
willst, dann installiere dir das doch einfach mal in
der VM und richte dir das mal vom
Scratch ein, so wie du es haben willst.
Da lernst du viel bei und dann hast du auch das genauso
wie du es am Ende haben willst.
Ja, Beste.
So muss das sein.
Atsch by the way.
Du hast ja einen Plan
für das neue Jahr. Gaming, kochen,
immer vernünftiges Lernmaterial mit eingetechnetem Fach.
Also, was ich mir,
ich hab mir nichts vorgenommen, also ich nenn's
jetzt mal so, aber ich hab mir nichts
vorgenommen fürs neue Jahr.
Ihr kennt mich, ich halte davon nix
und
ich denke die Statistik gibt mir da auch recht
dockerized art.
Ja, gibt's auch, aber
für Desktop-Virtualisierung ist
das nix. Probier's mal lieber
mit ner VM.
Die Statistik gibt mir da auch recht, Neujahrsvorsätze
sind Mist und halten nicht.
Was ich mir aber, ich nenn's jetzt trotzdem mal,
vorgenommen habe, beziehungsweise eigentlich schon
die ganze Zeit auch vorhab, ist das
weiterzumachen, regelmäßig rennen
zu gehen und Fahrrad zu fahren.
Und was ich mir auch vorgenommen hab, aber
nicht als Neujahrsvorsatz, sondern
weil ich das haben will, ist ein neues Fahrrad
kaufen. Weil meins ist ja hier
nicht mehr straßentauglich,
aber Heimtrainer-tauglich,
glücklicherweise. Und ich warte
jetzt noch, bis es wieder was in meiner Größe zu
liefern gibt. Am besten natürlich, wenn's
das dann mit 1x12-Schaltung gibt.
Das werd ich mal irgendwann im Laufe des nächsten
Jahres dann kaufen. Und dann wird
wieder, gerade wenn's jetzt wärmer wird,
wird wieder geradelt.
Wayland ist immer noch in der
VM verbuggt. Zumindest, wenn ich's manuell
installiere mit Sway.
Wenn man offizielle
Distributionen verwendet,
äh, wenn man den offiziellen Desktop von
Distributionen verwendet, wie von
Ubuntu oder Fedora oder so, dann geht das
auch mit Wayland.
Aber bei mir ist es verbuggt.
Und Copy-Paste
funktioniert bei mir auch beispielsweise mit Wayland
in der VM nicht richtig. Es ist alles etwas
eklig. Ja, Hyperland
ist cool, aber Hyperland ist auf jeden Fall nix
in der VM.
Und auch was für Wayland.
Da, also wenn du Hyperland verwenden willst,
dann musst du es wirklich native installieren.
Das klappt in der VM nicht richtig.
Korrekt.
Ich würde tatsächlich genau das, was
MrGaming schreibt, Linux Mint ist
echt nicht verkehrt. Cinnamon Edition, also
Standard Linux Mint, ist wirklich
einsteigertauglich.
Einsteigertauglicher
wird's wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Du hast dir vorgenommen, etwas
mehr based durch das Jahr
zu gehen. Okay, wie darf
man sich das vorstellen? Wie geht man
based durch das Jahr?
Ist das eine Umschreibung für entspannter?
Oder
was muss man machen, um based zu werden?
Ja, habe
ich jetzt, kaufe ich mir auch wieder.
Und
das liegt jetzt nicht daran, weil ich so gerne
irgendwie auf
Schotterwegen fahre, sondern
weil die Gravel-Bike-Geometrie
einfach für Noobs wie mich
etwas angenehmer ist, als von einem Rennrad.
Based ist
zum Beispiel zu sagen, dass man mehr based ist
und sich weiter zu erläutern verstehe.
Ist das ein bisschen was Richtung
ähm, ne fällt mir jetzt
nichts ein.
Kann man sich irgendwie
versichern gegen Unfälle? Doch.
Also, ich bekomme
das Geld von der Versicherung für das Fahrrad, was
kaputt ist, aber die haben
noch nicht bezahlt.
Warum ist das nicht mehr straßentauglich?
Hattest du es nicht erst gekauft? Doch.
Aber ich wurde umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg.
Keck wait.
Oh ne, hör mal bloß auf.
Da muss man sich ja richtig anstrengen für.
Da mache ich lieber Kreiselgrind.
Wann Viewer radeln auf
Swift?
Du wirst lachen, ich habe es mir sogar überlegt schon
und ich wollte tatsächlich
am Wochenende es mal ausprobieren.
Allerdings nicht Viewer radeln, sondern einfach
mal eine Runde fahren, so zur Motivation mit ein paar Leuten
hier dabei. Und da ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ich nicht in der Lage bin, meinen
Trainer, also meinen Smart-Trainer
über Bluetooth gescheit zu verbinden.
Ich kann ihn zwar über Bluetooth verbinden,
aber dann nur
den Leistungsmesser und nicht
die RPM und die...
Was ist die andere Sache noch?
Irgendwie hat er nur einen Sensor
von drei erkannt, was ziemlich kacke ist.
Also braucht wahrscheinlich...
Ich habe einen Wahoo
Kickr Core. Ich brauche
wahrscheinlich so einen N plus Stick.
Na steuer... Ich habe keinen
Controller dafür.
Ich finde Mint ist top.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Michael, 5 Billionen.
Moin, auch wieder am Start.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen,
ich freue mich, dass du wieder da bist
und wie war dein Neujahr und sowas, aber du weißt,
ich bin kein Mann solcher
Worte. Aber trotzdem schön,
dass du wieder da bist. Ich erspare dir
die Fragen, auf die ich auch keinen Bock hätte.
Aber 42 Monate.
Sag mal, wie
sieht es eigentlich mit Cannabis-Legalisierung
aus? Sollte das nicht schon
irgendwie
mal langsam sein?
Oder kriegen sie es mir doch nicht
gebacken? Murmeln, du hast recht.
Du musst was trinken, ja.
Legal ist es nicht. Am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
interessiert es aber keinen.
Ich habe euch doch erzählt, ich war letztens mit einem Kollegen
Mittagessen in Frankfurt, haben wir Geld abgehoben
am Geldautomat und
direkt neben uns stehen drei
Schwarze und dealen irgendwas.
Einfach offen, mitten auf der Straße
random, juckt einfach keiner.
Was kostet so ein N plus
N plus
Dongle für ein PC?
Das ist ja nix!
13 Euro!
Das wäre ich mir jetzt gleich...
Handy, Amazon App.
Bestelle ich mir jetzt gleich ein
und dann ist gut.
N plus
Dongle.
Lieferbar.
Wie, morgen ist da nix lieferbar?
Was ist mit euch los, Amazon, Mann?
Okay, Mittwoch.
Aber morgen bringt ja eh nix.
Nicht N plus,
N plus.
Für meinen Smart Trainer,
dass ich den mit dem PC verbinden kann.
Bestelle ich doch jetzt einfach mal hier
irgendwie einen von
den China-Chinesen-Dingern.
Die haben alle scheiß Bewertungen.
Was ist denn das?
Was hast du denn für einen?
Den hier.
Okay, den bestelle ich jetzt einfach.
Okay.
Dann...
Ich bestelle so ein Billig-Ding.
Warum gibt es da wieder so 30.000 Sachen zur Auswahl?
Was ist denn das?
Ich bestelle so ein 15 Euro Billig-Ding
und gucke einfach, ob das taugt oder nicht.
Ja.
Zack, bestellt.
Gut.
Hast du auch einen Lüfter?
Einen Fan?
Gestern hat ein Update erstmal
meinen Arch zerstört.
Besser hätte das ja nicht enden können.
Ja, ich hoffe, du hast
einen Snapshot.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal meine alten Snapshots löschen.
Den können wir jetzt wieder löschen.
Weg damit.
Ja, ich habe jetzt so einen 14 Euro Stick gekauft.
Hast du nicht mal T-Shirts bestellt?
Wie waren die von der Qualität?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, welche das gewesen sind.
Baderdingsbums, danke schon für den Sub.
Weiß ich nicht mehr, welche das waren,
die ich, wo ich erzählt habe, dass ich mal hier bestellt habe.
Morgen kein Bock auf Arbeit.
Du auch nicht?
Willkommen im Club.
Viel weniger.
Viel mehr Bock kann man eigentlich gar nicht
auf irgendwas haben.
Und wie weit hat ein CR-Root
deinen Arch wieder gefixt?
Du musst fixen, dass
AMD-V wieder funktioniert.
Siehst du mal,
ich hatte so lange keine AMD-CPU.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was
AMD-V ist.
Ist das das Gegenstück zu VTD?
Also bei Intel ist ja VTD.
Intel?
Ah ja, okay.
Also Virtualisierungskrempel.
Ja, okay.
Timeshift und Arch.
Timeshift ist für mich,
wenn man beim Fernseher auf Pause drücken kann
und dann vor- und zurückspulen.
Keka Headwind, was kostet denn das?
Da ist jetzt etwas
leicht sidetracked.
Boah!
Ein Lüfter für 313 Euro!
Was ist denn mit dem kaputt?
Also man kann es auch
übertreiben, oder?
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur
bei Amazon so teuer.
Ne, da kostet es 280 Euro.
Und da kostet es 230 Euro.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein krasser
Preis für ein Lüfter.
Aber gut,
der muss halt auch ordentlich Luft
umsetzen.
Ist AirSync
BTFS based system?
Achso.
Okay, habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
Ich mache immer AirSync.
Manuell oder automatisch.
Fertig.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das ist das Ding, dass ich hoch und runter fahren kann.
Aber ich will ja keinen neuen Trainer.
Ich habe ja schon einen.
Gut, für mich erst mal.
Ja.
Jetgear.
Mal gespannt, was 2024
so auf uns alles zukommt.
Bin mal gespannt,
was aus dem Deutschlandticket wird.
Wenn das irgendwie
abgeschafft wird, bin ich
super pisst.
Ich halte ja eh schon alle für wahnsinnig
unfähig und
das Deutschlandticket
war
eigentlich die einzige Sache, die mein
Leben von allen den Dingern, die
die letzten, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre
oder so, da so politisch passiert sind,
wirklich mal zum Positiven
verändert hat. Spürbar.
Wenn sie das wieder abschaffen, ey,
dann bin ich echt durch mit dem ganzen Scheißladen.
Pack mich genauso ab wie die Bahn.
Was meint ihr, was passiert mit dem
Deutschlandticket? Es wird auf jeden Fall teurer.
So viel ist schon mal sicher.
Das finde ich wiederum auch gar
nicht so schlecht.
Besser ein bisschen teurer als
abschaffen. Wenn das...
Man muss nämlich mal echt sehen,
das Deutschlandticket war eine wirklich
richtig riesen Verbesserung für viele Leute.
Und
gerade auch im Hinblick auf dessen,
dass du dich nicht mehr mit irgendwelchem
Verkehrsverbund-Scheiß und so
auseinandersetzen musst.
Aber ich würd's nicht wundern, wenn das das einzig
Gute, was es die letzten Jahre über in der Richtung da
Neues gegeben hat, wenn das
nicht wieder irgendwie
abgeschafft wird und so.
Ich hab da,
ich hab's schon oft gesagt, ich hab da eh eigentlich schon mehr oder
weniger abgeschlossen. Ich rechne nicht damit,
dass irgendjemand irgendwas entscheidet,
was in meinem Interesse
ist, beziehungsweise irgendwie
das berücksichtigt,
was ich mir wünsche. Insofern
wird das alles wurscht.
Der Markt regelt das, Leute.
Wisst ihr doch.
Mein nächstes Wahlwett schon wieder absolut keine Ahnung haben, was ich wählen soll.
Ey, es ist, ja,
das ist genau das gleiche. Das ist halt richtig,
also beim Deutschlandticket
versus früher, da hast du halt
mal den direkten Vergleich gesehen,
wie kacke das gewesen ist.
Du musstest früher
teilweise gucken, wenn du,
Beispiel, wir machen mal
ein ganz konkretes Beispiel. Als ich das letzte Mal
auf der Gamescom war,
ist schon eine Weile her.
Da musstest du dir in Köln noch eine
Wochenkarte holen.
Da bin ich an Automat, hab mir eine Wochenkarte
geholt. Da war schon mal gar nicht so genau
klar, welche Stufe der Wochenkarte
ich eigentlich brauche.
So, dann bin ich, dann hab ich mir die vermeintlich
richtige Stufe der Wochenkarte geholt
und dann kam die Karte aus dem
Automat und unten drunter
stand nur gültig,
also ich habe diesen Automat
Geld bezahlt und danach kam eine Karte raus
und unten auf der Karte
stand nur gültig,
mit, keine Ahnung,
Köln-ID-Nummer oder sowas.
Habe ich mir gedacht,
was? Was wollt ihr
von mir? Also erstens ist es rechtlich
sicherlich fragwürdig, mich das erst bezahlen zu lassen
und dann ist es nur gültig mit.
Was wollt ihr von mir? Da habe ich
bei der Hotline angerufen von dem
Kölner Verkehrsverbund und da meinte
die so, ja, das kann ich ihnen auch nicht sagen,
aber sie können ja mal hier bei uns am Bahnhof
in die Kölner
Verkehrsverbund Zentral, Dingsda,
Beratung gehen. Ich meinte, Alter,
ich will einfach nur bei euch eine Woche lang
mit
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln fahren,
ich will keine Beratung, ich will mich damit
nicht irgendwie großartig belasten,
auseinandersetzen, ich will einfach nur eine fucking
Fahrkarte haben, die ich außerdem schon bezahlt
habe. Habe ich so nicht gesagt, ja.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
Da habe ich mal just for fun dem Busfahrer
das gezeigt, wo wir dann eingestiegen sind,
da habe ich den Busfahrer gefragt, hier, gucken sie mal,
da gibt es unten sowas, wo da steht nur gültig
mit welcher Nummer. Ich habe gesagt, welche Nummer denn?
Ich habe mir das Ding am Bahnhof gerufen und er hat gesagt, ach,
keine Ahnung, das versteht keiner.
Hat uns durchgewunken.
Das sind so Dinger, wo du dich so fragst,
was ist das für ein Schwachsinn, ja?
Es wollte auch keiner irgendwas sehen von uns.
Und das sind so Sachen, die haben das
Deutschland-Ticket halt komplett, komplett
gefixt. Über die App wollte
ich das damals machen, da
musstest du dich erst umständlich registrieren
und an jedem Registrierungs-Step
bin ich als Nicht-Kölner gescheitert damals.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann noch irgendwie eine Probe
oder eine Überweisung machen musste zur
Identifizierung oder so komisches Zeug.
Hat zumindest nicht mehr hingehört.
Also, deswegen, ich habe mein Deutschland-Ticket,
auch wenn ich, streng genommen,
es sich für mich gar nicht rechnet,
für einmal die Woche fahren.
Ich wäre theoretisch sogar ein bisschen billiger, würde ich
einfach so das bezahlen.
Naja,
nee, wäre ich nicht.
Stimmt nicht, was ich sage. Ich glaube, es kostet ja
mittlerweile 18 Euro oder so
eine Tageskarte oder sowas
nach Frankfurt und zurück.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was. Aber das ist halt
was, was das Deutschland-Ticket komplett gefixt hat.
Und das würde mich echt so
abfacken, wenn das wieder weg ist.
Ey, ich habe noch nicht mal vor, die zu
verarschen. Ich habe einfach
nur keinen Bock mehr auf diesen ganzen Verkehrsverbund-Shit.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich hoffe.
Es gibt ja schon wieder Diskussionen
für nächstes Jahr, ob das,
also teurer wird es wahrscheinlich, aber
das verstehe ich sogar noch irgendwo.
Aber die sollen das unbedingt beibehalten.
Sollte das abgeschafft werden,
würde das abermals
mein,
ja, wie soll ich sagen, mein eh schon
nicht vorhandenes Vertrauen
untergraben.
Ja.
Das geht aber auch nur,
wenn der Kontrolleur nicht weiter genauer
nachguckt, oder?
Weil bei mir wollen sie oftmals,
dass man das antippt
oder hoch und runter scrollt, wollen sie bei mir oftmals.
Dass man hoch und runter scrollt.
Wobei man das im Screenshot auch machen könnte.
Aber manche, manchmal wollten sie sogar, dass man vor und zurück
in der App geht und sowas.
Also sie sind da schon, also ich glaube nicht, dass man dauerhaft
mit einem GIF durchkommt.
Außerdem brauchst du ja auch
ein gültiges GIF.
Gibt's da keine Scanner für?
Doch!
Doch, gibt Scanner für.
Du musst da so eine Art QR-Code zeigen
und das scannt er dann.
Ich, da würde ich, so weit würde ich gar nicht mal gehen,
dass absichtlich das gemacht wird,
es ist eher so, dass ich das Gefühl hab,
es wird nichts gemacht von dem, was mir
persönlich wichtig war, beziehungsweise
wo ich sagen würde, hey, ich hab ja nichts dagegen,
hab ich ja auch nicht Steuern zu bezahlen,
aber es wäre cool,
wenn man sieht, dass von den vielen Steuern,
die ich bezahle, das ist wirklich nicht wenig,
auch ein bisschen was ankommt da,
wo ich Bock drauf hab, so.
Mal gucken, wie der Internet-Ausbau läuft,
Leute, der Glasfaser-Ausbau.
Das wäre so ein Thema, was mir wichtig wäre,
der ja jahrelang schleifen gelassen wurde
und letztes Jahr wurde ja angefangen,
richtig Attacke zu machen,
mit einem,
wie haben sie es genannt,
mit irgend so einem Maßnahmen-Fahrplan
oder sowas,
mit zentralem Regist,
nee, nicht, wie hieß das, zentrales Ausbau-Ding,
ach, keine Ahnung,
davon wird wahrscheinlich eh die Hälfte dann umgesetzt
und mal gespannt,
wann es bei mir dann wirklich Glasfaser gibt.
Aber das frage ich mich auch,
wie das mit dem Screenshot klappen soll.
Ich würde die aber auch nicht bescheißen,
rechtfertig, dass das die Sachen kostet,
die es kostet.
Oh nee, hör mal bloß auf.
Fahrrad-Infrastruktur-Ausbau habe ich mich
das letzte Mal schon drüber aufgeregt.
Bei uns sind zwei Fahrradwege geplant,
irgendwie gefühlt seit über zehn Jahren
und das letzte, was man von diesen
zwei Fahrradwegen gehört hat,
also, nein, kein einfacher Fahrradweg,
sondern, ich glaube, ein Fahrradschnellweg
nennt sich das sogar,
das ist quasi so eine Fahrrad-Autobahn,
was direkt nach Frankfurt durchgeht,
wo du auch permanent quasi Vorfahrt hast
und ordentlicher Fahrradweg.
Das letzte, was ich gehört habe,
ist, dass wieder eine Machbarkeit,
eine erneute Machbarkeitsstudie angefertigt wurde.
Da weißt du,
es geht auf jeden Fall nicht los in nächster Zeit.
Mal guckt euch das an.
Hanau, Frankfurt,
Fahrrad-Schnellstraße
oder so.
Warum hier?
Warum der Rad-Schnellweg?
Okay, ja.
Hier,
die zwei.
Hier, nördlich des Mainz,
Hanau, Frankfurt,
südlich des Mainz.
Wäre für mich persönlich mega nice.
Gerade jetzt, wo ich mehr Fahrrad fahre.
Und
das Ding ist halt,
wenn man sich das hier anschaut,
oder hier der Südmainz,
interessiert mich eigentlich mehr.
Also wir sind gerade,
also das Ganze wurde
erdacht
und dann wurde 2020,
man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
wurde eine Machbarkeitsstudie
in Auftrag gegeben.
Diese wurde im März
2023 fertiggestellt.
Die haben ohne Scheiß
zweieinhalb
Jahre
für die Machbarkeitsstudie
gebraucht.
Was meint ihr denn, wie lange das dauert?
Wenn die Machbarkeitsstudie schon zweieinhalb
Jahre dauert,
wann wird eigentlich der Radweg überhaupt angefangen
wird zu bauen?
Guck mal, die Aufzeichnung von einer Online-Informationsveranstaltung
2012.
wurden Ziele und Vorgehen
der Machbarkeitsstudie erläutert.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das Ding, die Planung ging vor über
12 Jahren los.
Vor über 12 Jahren!
Und das krasseste,
was sie bis jetzt geschafft haben dafür ist,
eine Machbarkeitsstudie
anzufertigen. Und der Witz ist,
der Anfang
zu bauen ist noch in
weiter Ferne.
Und das Bauen
selbst dauert ja dann auch nochmal ewig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich überhaupt noch
Fahrrad fahren kann, wenn der fertig
ist. Aber mit sowas,
es ist aber ernsthaft so,
mit sowas förderst du
sowas.
Genau mit sowas.
Mal gucken, wie es um den Nordmainischen
steht.
Da wurde die Machbarkeitsstudie übrigens
2019 schon veröffentlicht.
Guck mal! Hier!
Also, Alter!
Zu diesem Zweck hat die
im Februar 2016
eine Absichtserklärung unterschrieben.
Sie haben eine Absichtserklärung
unterschrieben, um eine
Machbarkeitsstudie zu erstellen.
Die haben noch nicht
eine Absichtserklärung unterschrieben,
um eine Machbarkeitsstudie zu erstellen.
Dann wurde
dreieinhalb Jahre später
eine Machbarkeitsstudie
veröffentlicht.
So. Und jetzt wurde
im Dezember oder im Spätsommer
2023 eine
weitere Machbarkeitsstudie.
Die haben sowas von
einfach nur krass den Arsch
offen in Deutschland mit Bürokratie.
Das ist nicht normal.
Ich kann kein Fahrrad mehr fahren,
wenn der fertig ist. Falls
es jemals fertig wird.
Das kann doch nicht sein, Mann.
Hehehe.
Wenn du in Hessen bist, warum?
Ist das woanders?
Dauert die Machbarkeitsstudie da nicht
dreieinhalb, sondern
viereinhalb Jahre?
Also wisst ihr, was ich wirklich
sehr nice finden würde?
Ich würde...
Ich würde sehr nice finden,
übrigens das ist auch eine super Sache,
wo man ein bisschen Kohle mitsparen könnte,
unnötig die Bürokratie einfach
weglassen.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich mir
vorgestellt habe, was nicht passieren wird?
Wenn wir einen sinnvollen
Weg finden würden zwischen
so wie wir es in China machen und so wie wir es jetzt machen.
In China wäre das Ding
fertig in einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Einmal quer durchs Land.
Wären halt vielleicht
im Fundament ein paar Bauarbeiter drin
eingegossen worden.
Oder was auch immer
sonst noch passiert wäre
in China.
Aber es wäre fertig gewesen.
Sonst ist in der Zeit erstmal
eine Absichtserklärung
zur Machbarkeitsstudie
erstellt worden.
Also es wäre mir ganz recht, wenn wir vielleicht
sowas schönes in der Mitte
fänden
könnten.
Also finden würden.
So nach dem Motto, wir brauchen
wir machen es nicht so
billig
und
rücksichtslos, wie es in China gemacht wird.
Aber wir machen es vielleicht auch nicht
ganz so übertrieben bürokratisch wie bei uns.
Sodass man vielleicht es schafft
einen neuen Fahrradwegen in 4-5 Jahren
hinzubekommen.
Anstatt in
40.
Ist halt echt der Witz man.
Also ganz ehrlich
ich glaube es gibt kein einziges Unternehmen
was sich nicht auch über die Bürokratie aufregt.
Genau.
MrBeast soll mal in Deutschland bitteschön Fahrradwege bauen.
Excellent.
Ich subscribe dann auch auf Youtube.
Du hast
es geschafft guter Dinge zu sein für 3 Viertel Tag.
Nice. GG Eats.
Ich mein ihr müsst, ihr dürft nicht vergessen
in Italien
in Italien haben die es geschafft.
Ich hab vergessen wo.
Aber das ist nicht einfach nur eine popelige Brücke.
Die haben es geschafft in Italien eine riesen Brücke
zu bauen innerhalb von einem Jahr.
War das denn?
Genua.
Ist das das? Ja.
Genau das ist da wo die Brücke eingestürzt ist.
So und das ist keine
kleine Furzbrücke. Guckt euch das mal an.
Also das ist
eine ordentliche Brücke.
Sowas was hier 40 Jahre
brauchen würde wahrscheinlich.
Die haben einfach eine Brücke
gebaut in einem Jahr. Fertig.
Hat funktioniert.
Nein. Würde ich aber gerne
spielen. Aber ich spiele keine
Alexis Spiele. Ich weiß was das ist.
Das ist von den ehemaligen Siedler
oder nicht von den ehemaligen
ist das falsche Wort. Vom
ehemaligen Siedler Erfinder
oder Miterfinder.
Eigentlich genau
mein Spiel, aber ich mag Early Access
auch nicht. Ich warte bis das raus ist.
Ich glaube das liegt bei uns auch daran, weil sich keiner so wirklich
für das gesamte interessiert, sondern
genau für seinen sehr überschaubaren
Horizont wenn es um bürokratische
Äkte geht in Deutschland.
Richtig. Genau. Die haben massig Verlust gemacht
und die
gerade die also quasi Händler
und Geschäftsbesitzer sind ja den Bürgermeister
da quasi auf der
die haben schon quasi bei dem im Wohnzimmer gesessen
wann es endlich wieder los geht. Der hatte gewissen
Druck dahinter ja. Aber bei uns
passiert das auch nicht. Trotzdem.
Das ist. Bei uns dauert sowas
30 Jahre. Was macht
eigentlich Stuttgart 21 wo wir gerade dabei
sind. Das ist eigentlich mittlerweile.
Nein ist es nicht. Wenn es fertig wäre hätte man das schon
mitgekriegt. Ne ne ich schau
ich schau nicht nach. Sonst wäre das wieder.
Aber das mit dem Fahrradweg das triggert
mich jedes mal wenn das wieder einer erzählt.
Das ist so dämlich man.
Oh. Jetzt habe ich mich aufgeregt
über den Fahrradweg und zack.
Zack.
Es ist 22.05
Leute.
Ihr wisst was das heißt.
Das heißt ich muss jetzt
Bettge
und morgen früh aufstehen und auf
die Arbeit fahren. Obwohl ich gar
keinen Bock hab.
Ne ich trink keinen Kaffee.
Das geht auch so.
Also Leute
wir sehen uns morgen. Bis dann machts gut.
See you.